THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER SEC. COULD
WE START WITH ROLL WALK SHE
LEFT BEFORE WE TO ROLL THE JUST
A- JUST DISCUSSED JUST TODAY
WE'RE DISCUSSING NINETEEN BILL
FOR THE PERMIT THE AGREEMENT
STARTING WITH D. B. EIGHTY NINE
THE AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE-
GOVERNOR THIS. IN THE ASSEMBLY.
IS AN INFORMATION HEARING ONLY
I WILL BE VOTE ON SEVENTEEN
ASSEMBLY GOALS THAT HAVE
ARRIVED IN THE SENATE INTO.
SENATE LATER TODAY. AGAIN THE
FIRST THIS RULES ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS. JUST DATA CENTER OUR
OWN BUDGET STAFF FOR THE ABLE
TO ON THIS DEPOT COM TODAY WILL
WORK A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY
THAN THE HOUSE IN THE PAST
THERE WILL BE NO. MONNING IN. A
CALM YOU DO HAVE TO. HEAR IN
PERSON IN ONE OF TO LOCATE. YOU
GOTTA COME TO ROOM FORTY TWO OH
TWO HERE IN THE CAPITAL. OR
YOU. TOO YOU CAN GO TO THE
SACRAMENTO STATE HARPER'S
ALUMNI CENTER. THIS IS A LARGE
INDOOR SPACE FOR WHICH PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AS WELL AS TO STAY
PHYSICALLY DISTANT. PAPER FOR-
HAVING THE HAVING THE HEARING
THERE WERE HAVING PEOPLE GO
THERE RATHER THAN. BEING
OUTSIDE WORKS QUITE QUITE. LET
US WITH- CALLING. TANK THERE
REGULAR PRESENT BLOOM COOPER
FONG MCCARTY OBERNOLTE HOWEVER.
SO. THANK YOU WE'RE HERE TODAY
TO- FINALIZE A BUDGET AGREEMENT
WE HAVE REACHED WITH THE
GOVERNOR. THE NIGHT. BEFORE US
REPRESENT A THREE PARTY
AGREEMENT TO MOVE THE STATE
FORWARD IN THIS DIFFICULT TIME.
IT MAKES REDUCTIONS IN STATE
SPENDING INCLUDES NEW REVENUES
BUT PROTECT THE INVESTMENTS IN
EDUCATION HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES SO OUR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES GET THE PROTECTION
THEY NEED DURING THIS PANDEMIC.
KEEPS ONCE WE KEEP THE BUDGET
WAS TODAY PERHAPS TEN BILLION.
RESERVE THE UNCERTAIN FISCAL
FUTURE THAT AWAY. I'M GONNA
OPEN UP TO SEE IF ANY MEMBERS
HAVE ANY OPENING COMMENTS AS
WELL. MR PROJECT. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND I'D LIKE TO
JOIN YOU IN THANKING OUR
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
AS WELL AS OUR CAUCUS COMMITTEE
STAFF I KNOW THAT OTHER BAND A
LOT OF SLEEPLESS NIGHTS IN THE
LAST WEEK AND- BUT EVERYONE NOT
MUCH WE APPRECIATE WORK
BECAUSE- THEY WILL YOU WITHOUT
THE EFFORT YOU PUT IN I AM.
THAT THE BUDGET CONSIDERING
THAT IS A LITTLE MORE FIST. THE
ONE THAT WE PASSED LAST WEEK
DAHLE REMAIN AYE AYE STILL HAVE
CONCERNS THAT REMAIN ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT IT'S STRUCTURAL
RESPONSIBLE. STILL REALIZE JUST
GENTLY ON GROWING ON- INTER
FUND TRANSFERS AND ON DEFERRALS
AND- I HAVE CONCERNS IT'S
TAKING THOSE ACTIONS THIS YEAR
WILL JUST MAKE IT HARDER TO.
BALANCE FUTURE YEARS I'LL BE
ASKING WHAT ABOUT THAT AS WE
SEE THROUGH THE HEARING TODAY
THANK. RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE BUDGET PACKAGE
BEING PRESENTED TODAY WILL HELP
ENSURE THAT NONE OF OUR
FAMILIES ARE LEFT BEHIND AS OUR
STATE GRAPPLES WITH BOTH THIS
MEDICAL. RECOVERY I WANT TO
THANK MY HELLO SO THE CHAIRS ON
OUR LEGISLATIVE LEADERS AND
MEMBERS OF THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR CONTINUING TO PUT FAMILIES
FIRST. THIS PANDEMIC HAS BEEN
LIKE NOTHING THE STATE HAS EVER
SEEN. AND THE SHEER FEROCITY
AND VELOCITY OF THE ECONOMIC
CONTRACTION WE EXPERIENCED HAS
BEEN LIKE NOTHING I'VE EVER
SEEN. LIKE TO ONCE AGAIN
REITERATE IT IS MY BELIEF THAT
OUR SAFETY NET PROGRAMS. THAT I
OVERSEE IN MY COMMITTEE AND
THAT THE- CLOSE UP AN INSURANCE
SHOULD BE PROTECTED AND
STRENGTHENS RIGHT NOW WHEN THEY
ARE NEEDED MOST JUST AS WITH
OUR QUICK ACTIONS ON FLATTENING
THE CURVE AT THE BEGINNING OF
THIS PANDEMIC THE FISCAL WHICH
THEM TAKE ON THE- DAY YOU POST
THE PACE FOR ECONOMIC GROWTH
AHEAD. SO WHAT GREEN. IN
VICTORIES IN THE PROTECTION OF
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES OUR
WORK IS NOT OVER. THAT IS WHY I
WILL CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR
HEALTH FOR ALL FOR EXPANDING
CALLIE E. I. T. C. FOR ALL
FAMILIES FOR PROTECTING THAT
CAN PROGRAMS THAT ARE OLDER
ADULTS RELY ON AND THE SERVICES
THAT ARE IS TO IMPROVE THE WELL
BEING OF OUR CHILDREN OR FOSTER
YOUTH AND THE- TOOLS WITH
FLEXIBLE AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. AT LEAST AS ABOUT
HIS DISCUSSIONS I ALSO WANT TO
BE CLEAR IN STATING THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THE DECISIONS THAT
WE MAKE AND EMPLOYMENT OUGHT TO
ACHIEVE EQUITY SOCIAL JOB. THE
IMPLICIT OR UNINTENTIONAL. I
LOOK FORWARD TO TODAY'S
DISCUSSION AND THOSE THAT LIE
AHEAD IN THE MONTHS AND WEEKS
TO COME. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY SEE
NONE WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO OUR
FIRST BILL AB EIGHTY NINE THIS
IS AN AMENDMENT. TO THE BUDGET
BILL DO WE HAVE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE DISTURBANCE FOR NATHAN
ON THE ON THE LINE. THANK GOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MISTER VICE
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. TO TAKE THIS ONE OUT
AND FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I ALSO HAVE SEVERAL OF
MY COLLEAGUES. ON THE PHONE-
SAID EXTENT AND ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS WILL INTO SOME DETAIL.
BE REFERENCE THAT AS WELL BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO OF THESE A-
BUT AS YOU MENTIONED MISTER
CHAIR. THAT FIRST BILL ON THE
AGENDA FOR EIGHT EIGHT EIGHTY
NINE WHICH IS IN A- TO THE
BUDGET BACK TWENTY TWENTY THAT
THE LEGISLATURE. ON JUNE
EIGHTEENTH COURSE IS A VERY BIG
BILL WITH ALL SORTS OF
DIFFERENT PROVISIONS OUT WHAT
I'LL DO RIGHT NOW IS JUST TO
THE- HIGHLIGHTS OF THE BILL
THAT TOTAL ESTIMATED. ENSURE
UNDER A SPELL ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITION- THE END OF
THE BUDGET WE ARE PROJECTS-
SERVICE ACT IN EWING EVEN AFTER
THAT INCLUDES. THE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE SIX RESERVE AND
EIGHT POINT BILLION DOLLARS IN
THE RAINY DAY FUND AFTER ONE
TRANSFER IS MADE FOR THE
BUDGET. IN ADDITION WE WOULD
TWO POINT SIX AND DOLLARS IN
THE SPECIAL FUND FRACKING
UNCERTAINTY IS TO ADDRESS.
EMERGENCIES OR OTHER PERSON
ADVANCE. LAST POINT I'LL MAKE
ABOUT THE STRUCTURE OF THIS
BILL- BASED ON A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- IS THAT IT DOES
INCLUDE. SO NOW WITH THE CUT
GOING TO A FACT BUT IF FEDERAL
FUNDS ARE RECEIVED BY OCTOBER
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY AND
WITH THE AMOUNT OF FOURTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS. THOSE CUTS
WILL BE RESTORED IN A IN A
WHILE NEGOTIATION AND
DISCUSSION. ABOUT THE CONTENT
THAT OUT SELECT. IN ELKS AND
DEFINE IF THE FEDERAL FUNDS TO
COMMAND BUT THEY'RE UNDER
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLARS THAT
WILL BE. ON A- BASIS. SO THAT'S
RIGHT. TO TAKE SINCE. QUESTION
THE COMMITTEE. BEFORE THE
QUESTION WE GO HELP MR PANIC
WITH LEO. GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND MR VICE CHAIR- AT
THIS TIME WE DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS BUT WERE
AVAILABLE FOR QUESTIONS. VERY
WILL WILL US FOR ALL THE
DIFFERENT BILLS ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MR IT'S NOT A QUESTION FOR MR
PADDOCK WELL WE'VE GOT YOU HERE.
THE STATE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES
US TO PASS A BALANCED BUDGET SO
THIS IS THE- AGREEMENT BETWEEN
THE LEGISLATURE AND THE
GOVERNOR AS TO HOW WE'RE GOING
TO BALANCE REVENUES WITH
EXPENSE YOURS BUT WONDERING
ABOUT YOUR OPINION OF WHETHER
NOT. BALANCE GIVEN THE FACT
THAT SO MUCH ON DEFERRALS ON
LOANSKNOWN INTER FUND
TRANSFERS TO ACHIEVE- THAT THAT
EQUILIBRIUM. BUT YES MISTER
OBERNOLTE- WELL I WOULD JUST
SAY UP FRONT THAT WE DON'T HAVE
A GREAT DEAL OF INSIGHT ABOUT
SOME OF THE DETAILS THAT GO
INTO THE PACKAGE- BUT- USE OF
DEFERRALS AND INTER FUND LOANS
ARE. A SOURCE AT ONE TIME
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE-
KICKSTAND THEY'RE SUFFICIENT TO
SUPPORT THE BUDGET YOU'RE
EXPENDITURES THEY COULD
CONSIDER. AS CONTRIBUTING TO
BUDGETARY BALANCE. SO YOU'RE
SAYING THAT YOU THINK THAT
THAT'S A PERMISSIBLE USE OF
THOSE FUNDS TAT WE CAN POINT
AT THIS BUDGET AND SAY THIS IS
A BALANCED. PERMISSIBLE IT DOES
TO SOME EXTENT YOUR RISK
TOLERANCE AND TO THE EXTENT
THAT THE ECONOMY DOES NOT
CONTINUE IN A RECOVERY MODE AND
IF THE IF THE RECOVERY BEGAN TO
ALTER OVER THE COURSE OF THE
COMING. THEN I THINK THE LATER
WOULD BE FACED WITH MAKING MORE
AND DEEPER- ONGOING ADJUSTMENTS
TO THE EXPENDITURE BASE- NEXT
YEAR SO TO SOME EXTENT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A CHOICE THAT YOU'RE
MAKING BY USING A ONE TIME
RESOURCES DISH THERE. WEST OF
THEM WERE BORN WE YEARS IF THEY
WOULD BE NAY. I CERTAINLY SHARE
YOUR AND I ALSO HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL CONCERN WHICH IS
THAT. I BELIEVE THAT THE
PURPOSE OF THE PROVISION OUR
STATE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES A
BALANCED BUDGET IS TO SAY WE
CANNOT DEFINITELY SPEND. OUT OF
A RECESSION THAT POWER THE
DEFENDER FROM IT HAS THAT.
CALIFORNIA DOES NOT HAVE AND I
FEAR THAT WHEN WE TRY TO
BALANCE OUR BUDGET BY BORROWING
FROM. FUNDS TO BE THE GENERAL
FUND WILL ALMOST TO PAY IT BACK
IN THE FUTURE NO DIFFERENT
REALLY THE DEFICIT SPENDING.
WITH THE TREASURY BONDS AWAY
THE GOVERNMENT AND SO. WHILE OF
THAT. CONCERN WITH THE IT THE
DEBATE ABOUT THE HAS BEEN
ACHIEVED SURE NOT. NINE OKAY
SEEING NONE WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR MAYBE EIGHTY NINE
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU LOST. IS
THERE ANYBODY IN A STOCK STATE.
WITH PUBLIC COMMENT AB EIGHTY
NINE. OKAY SEEN DONE THEN WE
WILL MOVE ON TO AB SEVENTY FIVE.
THIS IS OUR SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATIONS BILL. MR
RESPONDED THAT. YES SO THE NEXT
BILL AB SEVENTY FIVE
SUPPLEMENTAL APPROPRIATIONS
BILL- OFTEN KNOWN AND PARLANCE
AS A DEFICIENCY PALE- BASICALLY
IS DESIGNED TO ADDRESS SOME
UNANTICIPATED COSTS THAT ARE-
COME ABOUT THE COURSE THE
CURRENT YEAR TWENTY NINETEEN.
THE BILL INCLUDES A LITTLE
MILLION OR IS RATE IN AN ENDS
AT IT HIGH LET IT INCLUDES ON A
COSTS RELATED TO THE CAMPFIRE
INCLUDE THOSE THAT THIS CALL
YEAR IF HOUSE WILDFIRE. BUT WE
ARE OF COURSE IN ALL. WE ARE
WHAT FOR THE KNOX MEMORY. FROM
THE FEDERAL. IT ALSO INCLUDES
COSTS RELATED CHAIR A PUBLIC
SAFETY POWERSHOT OPTION
COMMUNITY POWER RESILIENCY AS
WELL AS- LEGALLY OBLIGATED
PAYMENTS IN MAN IT'S- WHETHER
FROM CAL FIRE OR CDC OP OR CDS.
I BE OUT WHAT AND I'LL MENTION
IS THE ALL FOODS. I COSTS
RELATED TO SECURITY ARE RELATED
TO THE RECENT PROTESTS AND
MAKING SURE THAT THERE WAS A
STATE GOVERNMENT FOR EVERYBODY.
I CITIES ACOSTA CROSS NUMBER
DIFFERENT FISCAL BACK IF
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT
ANY PROVISION NOT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER AND FOLKS ON THE PHONE
AS WELL. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS FOR I'M ASSUMING LA-
DOESN'T HAVE ANY FURTHER
COMMENT ON ANY OF THE
ADDITIONAL TRAILER BILLS.
QUESTION FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY SEEING NONE LET'S MOVE ON
TO THE NEXT BILL. AB SEVENTY
EIGHT. YES AB SEVENTY EIGHT
FIRST I TO THE I BANKRUPT
CALIFORNIA INFRASTRUCTURE
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT THANK AND
WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DOIS IT
WOULD ESTABLISH A CLIMATE
CATALYST FOR OF ALL ON FIND A
NIGHT THAT. THIS WILL MAKE ANY
POSSIBLE FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
MORE ATTRACTIVE- WHEN THEY HAVE
A PLACE TO DEPOSIT THAT
FUNDING- AND THIS FUND WOULD
BE. ADMINISTERED BY THE AYE
BANK BUT WITH HELP FROM THE WEB
OR FORCE NOT AGENCY. AS
DISTRICT ROAD COUNT. ONE
EMPHASIZE THAT. IS WAITING TO
GHOST AN AGREEMENT THE ADMIN.
FINE NO BY WILL BE APPROPRIATED
FROM DAYS FIND- WITHOUT THAT%
CONSENTED SELECT. THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS ON AB SEVENTY EIGHT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN- WHEN
I WATCHED THE HEARING ON THE
SENATE SIDE I SAW OUR SENATOR
FROM THE INLAND EMPIRE SPEAK
ABOUT A PROGRAM THAT I ALSO
WANTED TO ELEVATE HERE ON THE
ASSEMBLY SIDE. THIS IS A
PROPOSAL THAT ARE GONE THROUGH
A POLICY COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE
TO. ADD A BIT OF- PERSONAL
REFLECTION ON A PROGRAM THAT WE
HAVE PASSED AT THE STATE CALLED
FORMATIVE CLIMATE COMMUNITIES.
AND AS WE LOOK TOWARD THIS AYE
BANK SPEND SOME OF THEIR FUNDS
ON I JUST WANT TO SPEAK
PERSONALLY TO. THE BEST
EXAMPLES OF THE MARK. THIS WAS
AN EXAMPLE WHERE OUR COMMUNITY
CAME TOGETHER AND IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITY A DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITY AND DECIDED FOR
OURSELVES WHICH PROGRAMS WE
WANTED TO INVEST IN TO MAKE A
DIFFERENCE AND TRANSFORM OUR-
IF WE MADE INVESTMENTS AND
THINGS LIKE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND PERMACULTURE GARDEN. WE
MADE INVESTMENTS INTO URBAN
GREEN. MAKING A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN A DISTRICT THAT
NEVER HAD SOME OF THOSE
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND I
JUST WANTED TO SPEAK TO THE
STRENGTH OF THIS PROGRAM AND
HOPE. THAT THIS AYE BANK CAN
FIND IT. TO WORK THROUGH THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TO
MAKE SIMILAR INVESTMENTS LIKE
THIS. INTO PLACES LIKE THIS
CYNICAL ABOUT THE PLACES LIKE
THE INLAND EMPIRE. PLACES THAT
HAVE HISTORICALLY NEEDED THOSE
TYPES OF INVESTMENTS AND- LOOK
INTO THE ADMINISTRATION TO
DRIVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU MISTER WILL NOT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MISTER VISIT
NATHAN HAD A QUESTION ABOUT THE
REVENUE BONDS THAT THIS TRAILER
BILL AUTHORIZES- THE CLIMB A
CATALYST REVOLVING LOAN FUND TO
ISSUE. OUT WHEN DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THAT THOSE WHAT
BONDS WOULD BE ISSUED AND HOW
WITH THOSE BONDS. SO IT'S A
RIGHT NOW AND I HAVE MY
COLLEAGUE- TO RESET CALVERT AS
WELL AS GOING COME ON THE LINE
IN TERMS OF THAT PROCEDURE- BUT
I WILL SAY THAT- RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THIS SPECIFIC FIND-
DOESN'T HAVE. THE MONEY IN IT
AND EVEN IF DID IT IN A
PROBLEM. JUST WAIT. REYES INTO
THOSE THINGS WERE HAPPEN BUT
LET ME TURN IT. AT TO RESEARCH
AND INTO QUITE IN TERMS OF
TALKING ABOUT. THE PROCEDURE
REPAIRS AND AS YOU KNOW THE AYE
BANK HAS OTHER PROGRAMS- THAT
MAY OPERATE IN A SIMILAR WAY SO
FIRST TO RESEND THEM TO QUITE.
GOOD MORNING TO READ THE COVER
FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES
THIS FUND IS A AND THAT'S
LANGUAGE SET UP A FRAMEWORK
PRINTED FUND IN ANTICIPATION OF
FUTURE FEDERAL FUNDS AND AGAIN
IT WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
APPROPRIATION. SO I'M NOT DON'T
HAVE THOSE BECAUSE IT SHOWS
THAT TIME. ALL RIGHT INDICATE
THAT CLICK HELP CALLUM
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I THINK
GENERALLY SPEAKING IT- BUT
BASIC LAID OUT THAT. WHETHER
THIS WOULD BE BONTA GRANT OR
THAT FINANCING STRUCTURE WOULD
ROUTE REALLY REALLY BE
DEPENDENT ON WHAT. THE AND-
GRAIN. IN PLACE THOSE OUR
PEOPLE THAT ARE PROVIDE THE
FIND OUR ORIGINAL WHICH ISN'T
CONTEMPLATED HERE WHAT INTO
BONDS PROGRAM BUT MORE O A
FINANCING PROGRAM TO ADDRESS
GAPS USING EXISTING- USING
GENERAL FUND MONEY. SO FOLLOW
ON QUESTION IF WE'RE NOT
ANTICIPATING ON USING BONDS TO
FUND. THE CLIMATE CATALYST
REVOLVING LOAN FUND THEN WHY IS
THERE LANGUAGE IN THIS TRAILER
BILL AUTHORIZING THE ISSUANCE
OF THOSE BONDS. SO I CAN SPEAK
TO THAT AND THEN- QUITE CAN WAY
AND ALSO THE REASON THAT WE
WANTED TO CREATE AS AS YOU KNOW
IN ANYWHERE IN THE GOVERNOR HAD
OPPOSED TO RAP FOR. YOUR PERIOD
PUTTING ONE PERSON GENERAL I'M
INTO A CLIMATE CATALYST ONE
PROPOSAL OF COURSE WITH THE
PANDEMIC ANY ECONOMIC FACTS-
THAT- FUN THINGS ROLLED AND IN
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. ARE THE KIND OF
KIND OF TIME THANK YOU- ASSETS
OF. NOT INITIAL THINKING THAT
WE HAD HAD IN JAN. THERE WERE
NOT BE BONTA ALL THE REASON THE
THAT LINE. IS IN THE TRAILER
BILL IS THAT WE FOR EXAMPLE.
LINK FROM THE FEDERAL BUT
FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS CONTINGENT ON
SAID IN SOME TYPE BOND PROGRAM.
BACKED BY THOSE FARMS. THEN
THAT CASE WE WANT TO RETAIN THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT OF COURSE
DOESGOT TO BE A- THE
LEGISLATURE. BEFORE WE CANNOT
ON THOSE FINES AS A BACK SO
THIS IS BASICALLY WELL WE HAD
ONE WAY OF DOING THINGS THAT WE
WANTED TO IN A DIFFERENT
ECONOMIC ENVIRONMENT. IF THE
FEDERAL INCOME GROWTH WITH
ANOTHER SET OF CONSTRUED. WITH
MAKE SURE WE CAN. IT WOULD BE
BACK. UNDER THE CAR I'M MORE WE
WERE TO ADD FIND IT WOULDN'T BE
A FUND OUTLOOK. I AM. I THINK
IT'S ON FOR THAT THE LANGUAGE
IS STILL THERE OF THE IN IS
CURRENTLY NOT TO USE. REVENUE
BOND THAT I THINK THAT WE
SHOULDN'T AUTHORIZE THE USE OF
REVENUE BONDS AND IN THE FUTURE
AS YOU SAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT- ALTERS THE
CONDITIONS FOR THE PROVISION OF
THE- THANK YOU CAN ALWAYS COME.
BACK TO US IN THE LEGISLATURE
AND THEN. GET THE OP STATIONED
AT THAT- THAT USED TO THE
PROGRAM I DON'T THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO HAVE IT TO HAVE
IT UP FRONT WHEEL BUT WORRIED
ABOUT DRIVING THE STATE FURTHER
INTO. THE WOODEN DON'T HAVE A
PLAN. BOB WITH THE RIVER. THANK
YOU. YOUR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY GOING TO PUBLIC
COMMENT ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
AB SEVENTY EIGHT. HI THERE IN
THIS ROOM FORTY TWO A TWO OR
AND SOCKS STATE. THE SET I JUST
WANNA CONFIRM A SHOCK STATE
WITH THIS. I WANNA MAKE SURE
THAT THAT IS OPERATING. OKAY
VERY GOOD IF WE MISS ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT WILL HAPPY TO COME BACK
TO IT LET'S GO TO AB THE NIGHT.
AB SEVENTEEN YES AB SEVENTY
NINE IS ABROAD BILL RELATED TO
HUMAN SERVICES AND I'LL MENTION
TWO OR THREE PROVISIONS VERY
BRIEFLY THE FIRST IS ON THE CAP
WORKS TIME CLOCK AND THE EXTENT
THAT NOT. FROM FOR MY TEST
SIXTY MONTHS WHICH IS THE
MAXIMUM ALLOWED UNDER FEDERAL
LAW. THIS WOULD GOING TO AFFECT
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AS
THE STATE UPDATES ITS SYSTEMS
ARE IN THE WAY REQUIRED TO
IMPLEMENT THIS PROVISION. IN
ADDITION GOING BACK TO A
PROPOSAL THAT WAS FIRST IN THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN JANUARY
THIS WOULD INCREASE THE CHILD
THE CALVERTS CHILD. GROUPS FROM
FIFTY DOLLARS WE STILL HUNDRED.
AND DOLLARS IT IS MORE ONCE
ALSO SOME THE CALPERS SYSTEM
AND INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
DIFFERENT PROVISIONS RELATED TO
RATES FOR AYE HSS AND DDS.
URGENT RESPONSE SYSTEM- AND
SEVERAL OTHER HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS. THANK YOU COMING BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE ANY COMMENTS
DR ED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN TOM FIRST OFF I JUST
WANTED TO TAKE A MOMENT AND
RECOGNIZE THE ADMINISTRATION
FOR WRITING AND HELPING US TO
CORRECT SIXTY TIME CLOCK IT
WHEN. IT DIFFICULT TO CHEAT
BENTON WAS NOT AN EASY LEFT.
THE ONE OF THE ISSUE. YOU HAVE
DONE AS PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WILL BENEFIT FROM
THAT I DIDN'T WANT TO SPEAK TO
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IF I
COULD- IS GOING TO CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP BETWEEN THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION TO HELP
WITH THE SEMI ANNUAL REPORTING.
AND WAS IF YOU. OF A OFFICE. TO
MAKE WE COULD COORDINATE
REPORTING BETWEEN THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SO THAT WE
CAN HELP THOSE BUT FINALLY
WANTED TO END WITH FIFTY ONE
WHICH IS THE WE ARE TO RESPONSE
SYSTEMS IN OUR OFFICE AS SOON.
TOM DELUDE. TO HONOR THE FACT
THAT YOU WERE WILLING TO
EXPEDITE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS BILL AS WE SEE DURING THIS
PANDEMIC THE NEED FOR IT MORE
THAN EVER. AS WE BOTH ECONOMIC
DISTRESS AND SCHOOLING PROGRAM.
SEC SIGNIFICANTLY HELP OUR TO
MEET SOME WANTED TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THAT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER. COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY IN THE PUBLIC
COMMENT ON AB SEVENTY NINE.
OKAY SIGNALS COULD AB AT MISTER
TWENTY FIFTH. EIGHT EIGHTY IS A
PROUD HEALTH BILL ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS RELATES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S COMMITMENT TO
REDUCING DRUG PRICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS AND THAT INCLUDES-
HEALTH CARE SERVICES WITH THE
AUTHORITY TO NEGOTIATE DRUG
PRICES ON BEHALF OF NON MEDI
CAL AS WELL AS MEDI CAL
RECIPIENTS INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
OTHER DRUG PROVISIONS A SEVERAL
PROVISIONS FOR. I KNOW OF OUR
CALVET. THANKS TO RESPOND TO
COPE IN NINETEEN- AS FOLLOWS
PROVISIONS TO HAVE THE STATE
CONTINUE TO MAXIMIZE ITS
REIMBURSED THIRTY. BATCH
PROGRAM BUDGET. TROLL NOTES IN
THIS THE FIRST IS THAT FIFTY
SIX FUNDING FOR- VALUE BASED
PAYMENTS AND RATE INCREASES IS
PRESERVED IN THE BUDGET YEAR
UNDER THIS PROGRAM HOWEVER MOST
OF THOSE PROGRAMS ARE SCHEDULED
FOR SUSPENSION ON JULY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I WITH THE
BULK OF PROPERTY SIX TEN
FUNDING GENERAL MEDI CAL GROSS-
AND THEN THE SECOND ITEM IS
THAT IN THE GUN BUDGET OF THE
GOVERNOR AND ANY PROPOSED EXT
KALPI TO UNDOCUMENTED RESIDENTS.
SIXTY FIVE DOT ORG OR OTHERWISE
ELIGIBLE. IN THE FINAL
AGREEMENT THIS DOES NOT HAVE
THAT PROVISION HOWEVER IT DOES
INCLUDE LANGUAGE SAYING THAT
THIS COMMITMENT WILL BE
PRIORITIZED IF THERE ARE IN THE
FUTURE SUFFICIENT RESOURCES TO
PAY FOR IT OVER THE MULTI YEAR
WENT UP. THANK YOU MISTER PHONE.
BUT STILL PALMER FINANCE COULD
YOU AS A COULD YOU GIVE ME SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THE MANAGED
CARE EFFICIENCIES SECTION. IT
STATES THAT THE AS YOU PROPOSE
THESE- RISK CORRIDORS AND PUT A
PROPOSED RATE CUTS THAT IT
SHALL BE IMPLEMENTED ONLY TO
THE EXTENT THAT ANY NECESSARY
FEDERAL APPROVALS ARE OBTAINED.
AND FEDERAL FINANCIAL
PROVISIONS AVAILABLE AND IS NOT
OTHERWISE JEOPARDIZE IS THERE
ANY REASON TO BELIEVE THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD RECEIVE APPROVAL
FROM CMS- AT TO ACHIEVE THE
SAVINGS TO THE STATE AND WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THE SAVINGS FROM
THE MANAGED CARE FOR HIS.
PROPOSALS WITH THIS PERTAIN
VERSE. BACK GOVERNMENT. YES SO
I HAVE RYAN MILLER ON THE LINE
I DON'T KNOW IF WE HAD THOSE
EXACT TYPES OF PERCENTAGES
ARREST MAKES WITH US RIGHT NOW
ABOUT RYAN KIDS. DO A OR ON OUR
HHS TEAM IN TERMS OF HOW WE'RE
LOOKING AT THE FEDERAL GUIDANCE
AND ALIGNMENT OF OUR MANAGED
CARE PROVISIONS WHEN. IT'S. HI
THIS IS RYAN MILLER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION. IS
ACTUALLY FAIRLY COMMON LANGUAGE
THAT WE INCLUDING IN MANY MEDI
CAL- PROVISIONS- I BELIEVE THAT
WE ALSO HAVE THIS LANGUAGE. IN
NOW SOME OF OUR- THAT WERE BY
STATUTORY CHANGES- CONCERNING
THE PROPERTY FIX THIS PENSION-
AND IT'S REALLY JUST A
PROTECTION TO ENSURE THAT WE
DON'T JEOPARDIZE- YOU KNOW THE
MANY BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
FEDERAL FUNDING THAT WE-
RECEIVE. REGULARLY BUT ALSO OF
COURSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE IN
RECEIVING AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW-
WHAT KIND OF BONUS FEDERAL
FUNDING- UNDER SOME OF THE
RECENT- FEDERAL STIMULUS. AND
CO GOOD RESPONSE BUT
ALTERNATIVE ACTUALLY TO MY
COLLEAGUE JACOB LAMB TO MEET
THE NEEDS TO SPEAK SOME OF THE
MORE DETAILED THE ASPECTS OF
THE QUESTION. ARTICLE ONE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I CALL
THE WRANGLER IS CORRECT THIS IS
FAIRLY STANDARD LANGUAGE THAT
WE INCLUDE IN THE MAJORITY OF
OUR MEDI CAL- TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE BECAUSE THIS IS A-
PROGRAM THAT RECEIVE FEDERAL
FUNDING WE DO NOT WANT TO MAKE
ANY CHANGES THAT WOULD FURTHER
JEOPARDIZE THAT FUNDING MOVING
FORWARD. I DO NOT HAVE THE
SPECIFIC FOLDER IN FACT FOR THE
EVENING. AND BUT I CAN'T. ALL
THAT UP AND SHARE WITH ALL.
THAT WOULD BE VERY MUCH
APPRECIATED OKAY BUT ARE YOU
ARE YOU PROJECTING SIGNIFICANT
SAVINGS COMING TO THE STATE OR
IS IT IS IT NATURALLY. IT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY OCCUR WHERE
SOME OF IT COMES TO THE STATE
AND SOME OF IT GETS SENT BACK
TO THE FOR A GOVERNMENT. BOB
PORTION OF THE SAVINGS WOULD BE
RETURNING TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT BECAUSE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WOULD NOT BE PAYING
THE SAME RATE. OF HOWEVER BASED
OFF. WHAT WE'RE TRACKING WE ARE
ASSUMING- SAVINGS OF EIGHTY
SEVEN POINT EIGHT MILLION
GENERAL FUND AND BUDGET YOUR
FROM THE MANAGED CARE OF
PATIENTS THE- AND- I CAN AND I
CAN PULL UP THE INFORMATION FOR
THE ONE POINT 5% RATE
ADJUSTMENTS OR WITHDRAW THAT
THAT BE PERFECT I APPRECIATE IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MISTER WHAT. THANK YOU THIS IS
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE-
YOU TESTIFIED THAT. THE
EXPANSION OF FULL SCOPE MEDICAL
BENEFITS TO UNDOCUMENTED
SENIORS WAS BEING- SUSPENDED
THIS YEAR BUT IT WAS GOING TO
BE PRIORITIZED IN FUTURE BUDGET
YEARS AND THERE'S LANGUAGE IN
THIS BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT
DEFINES THE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH- THAT WOULD OCCUR. AND
LINKS IT TO THE BALANCE OF THE
SFE YOU FUND- HOWEVER WERE
MAKING A LOT OF OTHER PAINFUL
CUTS IN THE BUDGET THIS YEAR
AMONG OTHER THINGS THAT'S OF
ALMOST A BILLION. TO CSU IN
PERSON IF CALIFORNIA'S ARE YOU
SAYING THAT IN FUTURE YEARS- AS
ECONOMY RECOVERS THIS EXPANSION
MEDI CAL WILL CURB FOR THOSE
CUTS ARE STORED. WHAT WE'RE
SAYING IS THAT THIS- WE'RE
SIGNALING THAT THIS WILL BE A
PRIORITY- THAT BEING SAID THE
LEGISLATURE OF WILL HAVE TO
APPROVE A BUDGET WITH FUNDING
FOR THOSE ITEMS IN IT BEFORE IT
GOES. FORWARD AND WE ARE
CERTAINLY HOPING THAT THE
ECONOMY WILL RECOVER AS
ROBUSTLY AS POSSIBLE BUT AS YOU
MENTIONED AT THE OUTSET MISTER
VICE CHAIR- WE DO HAVE SOME
WAYS. TO GET THERE. OKAY WELL I
MEAN JUST PERSONALLY ON ON A
HOT I KNOW I'M NOT ALONE IN
THIS I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH.
SAYING THAT WE'RE GOING TO-
PRIORITIZE. EXPANDING THIS
ENTITLEMENT PROGRAM AHEAD OF
RESTORING THE CUTS THAT WERE
HAVING TO MAKE. TWO OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT ALREADY EXIST
THIS YEAR SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT'S THE COMPROMISE THAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO. THE
BUDGET MOVE POOR BUT I THINK
IT'S VERY TRUE. THAT THE
LANGUAGE WAS WRITTEN IN THE WAY
WAS. GREAT THE THANK YOU MISTER
IN YOU KNOW I THINK OF THIS
PANDEMIC HAS TAUGHT US ANYTHING
IT'S THAT THE HEALTH OF EACH OF
US IS DEPENDENT ON THE HEALTH
OF ALL OF US. AND THAT SHOULD
BE A RALLYINGCRY FOR WHY WE
WORK TOWARDS HEALTH FOR ALL.
AND I KNOW THAT THE GOVERNOR
HAS THE DRIVE TO WORK TOWARDS
UNIVERSAL COVERAGE. AND THAT
THE INTENSE LANGUAGE THAT'S
PRESENT IN THIS BILL WHILE NOT
PERFECT IS. STILL WORKING
TOWARDS IT ANTI WANTED TO ECHO
SOME OF THE CONCERN AND
FRUSTRATION I OUR CALL ON THE
SENATE SIDE FROM LOS ANGELES.
AND ELEVATE THE ISSUE BUT KNOW
THAT WE WILL HAVE A LOT OF WORK
TO DO BUT I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
LEADING ON THAT ISSUE. AND
WORKING WITH OUR DOCTOR
POPULATION TO GET THEM COVERAGE
RIGHT NOW THROUGH THIS PANDEMIC.
WHILE WE'RE ON. EIGHTY THOUGH I
WANTED TO TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT YOUR SUPPORT. YESTERDAY
SENATOR BELL HAD SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT AND WAS ASKING ABOUT A
WAIVER THAT CURRENTLY THE
ADMINISTRATION IS SEEKING. AND
I WOULD JUST ECHO SUPPORT FOR
THE INCLUSION OF PEER SUPPORT
AND THAT WAIVER REQUEST AS IT
MAY ALLOW US TO PULL DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS AND UTILIZE SAY-
OF NEW WORST WAY FOR US TO
BETTER MEET PEOPLE WHERE
THEY'RE AT. I THINK WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO SEE AFTER THIS
PANDEMIC IS A TSUNAMI OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AND SUBSTANCE
USE DISORDER ISSUES AND THAT WE
ARE GOING TO NEED PEER SUPPORTS
pTSUNAMI AND WE JUST ASK THE
ADMINISTRATION. TO PREPARE FOR
IT BY INCLUDING IT IN THEIR WAY
FOR THAT THEY'RE MAKING TO OUR
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU EITHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS. OKAY LET'S
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. OTHER AT FORTY TWO A
TORN SACK STATE. NOT SINGLE
PUBLIC COMMENT LET'S MOVE TO AB
AT ONE SERVICE ONE AT THAT. AB
AT WHAT DOES THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH- TRAILER BILL AND THE
KEY PROVISION OF THIS IS THE
EXTENSION OF THE WHAT'S KNOWN
AS THE COST THIS IS THE QUALITY
ASSURANCE FEE FOR SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES ARE THIS
BILL ALSO PROMOTES VARIOUS
QUALITY MEASURES AND COMPLIANCE
WITH REQUIREMENTS. FOR THE
START NURSING PLEASE AND THEN
THE OTHER ITEM OF NOTE THAT I
MENTIONED THIS BILL IS RELATED
TO THE MENTAL HEALTH. SPEND THE
REVERSION OF THOSE FINES FROM
COUNTIES- AND SOLDIER WHY ONE
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. ANY
QUESTIONS. DR EMILY THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND AGAIN I WANTED
TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF OUR
SENATE COLLEAGUES DR PAN ON
THIS ISSUE IF I COULD WHEN HE
SPOKE ABOUT INCREASED
FLEXIBILITY OF THE METAL
SERVICES ACT FUNDS TO COUNTIES
IT'S GOING TO BE INCREASE
FLEXIBILITY WHAT THINK IS
APPROPRIATE PANDEMIC I DO
BELIEVE WE SHOULD HAVE MORE ON
ABILITY TO THE COUNTY SAYS.
THANK SURE THAT. SERVICE ACT
LARGER BEINGS NOW. IN THE
MIDDLE OF A PANDEMIC WHEN WE
HAVE NEEDS SEEMS APPROPRIATE
FROM THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
OVERSIGHT AND SHOULD BE ASKING
FOR THAT ACCOUNTABILITY. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. OKAY SEE NOT ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. SINGLE PUBLIC
COMMENT WAS GOOD AB EIGHTY TWO.
AB EIGHT HERE IS THAT GENERAL
STATE GOVERNMENT TRAILER BILL
NUMBER PROVISIONS I'LL JUST
MENTION THREE OF THEM FIRST IS
RELATED TO THE- CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT- SHIFTING SOME
INVESTIGATORS FROM THE DIVISION
OF INVESTIGATIONS TO THE BUREAU
CANNABIS CONTROL A SECOND ITEM
OF THIS BILL OF NO FOR WAYS TO
BROADBAND. AS MANY OF YOU KNOW
THERE'S A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
A FEDERAL COMMUNICATIONS
COMMISSION. FUNDING GRAHAM
WHICH CALIFORNIA Y. TO DO APPLY
LOGIC. PRINT INFRASTRUCTURE AND
THIS TRAILER BILL BASICALLY
NUMBER ASK CHANGES RELATED TO
THE STRUCTURE OF THAT
CALIFORNIA ADVANCED SERVICES
FUND ENABLE THE STATE BETTER
COMPETE FOR THOSE GREAT. NAY BY
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION.
TO PROVIDE A FUN. IT'S RELATED
TO COLLECTION OF USED CAR SALES
TAX. ANY QUESTIONS MISTER
BROUGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
I'VE FIVE MOST OF THE
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL
SUPPORTABLE BUT I HAVE CONCERNS
ABOUT A NEW PROGRAM ESTABLISHED
IN THE TRAILER BILL AND I
WONDER IF YOU COULD TELL US
WHAT YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE IT'S A LOT EARNERS FOR
NET AND ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
GRAHAM TELL ME WHY THAT'S BEEN
INCLUDED HOW MUCH FUNDING IS
ALLOCATED TO IT. YES ON THIS
LET ME TURN IT OVER TO I'VE GOT
ERICA LEE ON THE PHONE AND
EITHER SHE OR SOMEONE ON THAT
WOULD AND A HAT THOUGH- THIS
UNIT WILL BE ABLE TO SPEAK TO
THAT. HI GANG UP AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION- THE PHOTO ON
PAGE ONE YOUR AD ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM WILL
PROVIDE TRAINING AND WORK
MICHAEL GRANTS TO INDIVIDUALS.
AT THE FIVE TARGET POPULATE.
SUPPORT THEM. MARCHING
ENTERTAINING OUR SMALL BUSINESS
IN THE STATE AND THEIR TEN
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME AND
BUDGET FOR THAT. THANK YOU AND
TELL US WHAT THOSE TARGET
POPULATIONS ARE. SURE AND AGAIN
DANIEL BRANDON FINANCE
INDIVIDUALS WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFESSOR PROFICIENCY
AB REGARDLESS OF THEIR
IMMIGRATION OR CITIZENSHIP
STATUS AND ALSO INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE NEED ARE UNITED STATES
CITIZENS AND LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENTS WHICH INCLUDED BUT
NOT LIMITED. ACTIONSCHILD
DIVIDE TEMPORARY PROTECTED
STATUS. LAW AND IS THERE A
PARALLEL SEED PROGRAM FOR
IMMIGRANTS THAT DO HAVE LEGAL
STATUS IN CALIFORNIA. SO I CAN-
IS IT JUST SPEAK MORE BROADLY I
THINK ONE OF THE REASONS FOR
THIS IS THAT THERE ARE A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT
PROMOTE ENTREPRENEURSHIP- AT
BUT THE STATE LEVEL AND THE
FEDERAL LEVEL INCLUDING IN THIS
OVERALL BUDGET PACKAGE- THERE
IS EXTENDED FROM THE MIDDLE
FRANCHISE TAX. THIS IS A MAP
YEAR SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS
PROGRAM IS TO PROVIDE A
COMPARATIVELY SMALL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING. FOR POPULATIONS THAT
MIGHT NOT HAVE ACCESS TO OTHER
RESOURCES. OKAY I UNDERSTAND I
FIND A VERY TROUBLING THOUGH
THAT WERE YOU MIGHT CONSIDER
TEN MILLION DOLLARS SMALL AND
MAYBE IN THE CONTEXT. OF THE
STATE BUDGET SMALL BUT IT'S A
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF TAXPAYER
MONEY AND I THINK THAT THE VERY
INAPPROPRIATE. THOSE FOUGHT
ESPECIALLY NEARLY A FIFTY
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET DEFICIT.
IN YOU KNOW MAY I HAVE A SMALL
BUSINESS BACKGROUND I'VE
ADVOCATED FOR SMALL BUSINESSES
AND CERTAINLY- SEED MONEY FOR
HELPING PEOPLE ESTABLISH A
SMALL BUSINESSES SOMETHING ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF. BUT TO
LIMIT THE ABILITY. AS WE DO IN
THE- BILL TO RESIDENTS THAT
LACK DOCUMENTED IMMIGRATION
STATUS I THINK IS A- SUCH A
SUCH A BAD PRECEDENT. THANK YOU
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY ANY PUBLIC COMMENT. ON AB
AT TO PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY THIS
MOVED AB EIGHTY THREE. AB
EIGHTY THREE IS THE HOUSING
TRAILER BILL- FIRST PROVISION
OF NOTE RELATES TO THE NATIONAL
MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT FUNDING AS
MANY OF YOU MAY RECALL LAST
YEAR- I DON'T MINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAD A LOT OF
DISCUSSIONS ON HOW EXACTLY TO
ALLOCATE. THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS ARE NOT PAID BY THE
COURT TO BE SPENT ON HOW IT
MATTERS AND THIS BILL GOT OUT
THREE MILLION OF A HUNDRED OUT
OF THAT TO A CAL HFA THE
HOUSING FINANCE AGENCY FOR
HOUSING COUNSELING SERVICE
THERE'S- BALANCED ONE DOLLAR GO
TO THE JUDICIAL. FOR AT THE- IN
OTHER RENT RECALLS THIS IS.
THAT'S MAJOR DIVISION OF
TRAILER BELT I'LL JUST MAKE ACT
OTHERS. FIRST IS RELATED TO
HOMELESSNESS FUNDING THIS BILL
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS IN GENERAL FUND- FOR
FUNDING FOR THE BIGGEST
THIRTEEN CITIES AS WELL AS
COUNTIES AND CONVENIENCE OF
CARESERVICE FUNDING. GO TO ALL
CORNERS OF THE STATE OF
FOLLOWING THE FORM. WAS NOT IN
THE- LAST. DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
RESOURCES. AT A CRITICAL TIME
ALSO. OUR NATION PLAN AND THEN
THE LAST I OF THIS BILL OF IS
THAT IT PROVIDES ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT FOR PROJECT ROOM KEY
AND THE RELATED TEMPORARY SEEK
EXCEPTION THAT PRO. THANK YOU-
SPEAKING OF PROJECT ROOM KEY-
pFOR HOW MANY PEOPLE BEEN HOUSE
STEP THROUGH THE PROGRAM UP TO
THIS POINT. AND ALL. OF ONE OF
THE PROVISIONS OF PRODUCT
PROJECT ROOM HE CALLS FOR WORK-
ON PURCHASING UNITS THAT MIGHT
BE AVAILABLE CAN YOU TELL ME
HOW MANY OF THE JUST TO DATE
AND JUST OVERALL. OF HOW MANY.
OF PEOPLE TWO WEEKS TO BE HOUSE
STAND TO HOW MANY UNITS
PURCHASED THROUGH THE FUNDING.
THAT'S ALLOCATED IN THIS BUDGET.
YES I'LL PROVIDE A VRY BRIEF
COMMENT AND ERICA LEE AND HER
TEAM ON THE PHONE APP MAY
HAPPEN MOST UP TO DATE NUMBERS.
IN GENERAL- WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
HOUSE AT OVER TWO THOUSAND.
EIGHT SEVEN SECURED I SINCE THE
PROGRAM STARTED A COUPLE OF
HOURS- ANY TERMS IN OCCUPIED
UNITS IN TERMS OF OVERALL UNITS
IT'S- OUR SERVICE AND THEN WHEN
IT COMES TO THE PURCHASE. PRO
THE HOPE THROUGH THIS BILL IS
TO TAKE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDS AND THEN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY NINE DOLLARS IN GENERAL
FUND TO PROVIDE FURTHER SUPPORT
FOR THE PROGRAM AND THAT
INCLUDES- FEDERAL SUPPORT
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW- THIS IS
BOTH THE HOMELESS. PROGRAM AND
A CO NINETEEN FIGHTING PROGRAM
BUT FOR THE SPECIFIC STATISTICS
THAT YOU MENTIONED- BASED ON
WHAT WE WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO
ERICA. GOOD MORNING PART IN A
FINANCE- SO FOR PROJECT ROOM
KEY HAS SECURED APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
ROOMS AND OF THOSE PROXIMALLY
TEN THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED-
OCCUPIED THOSE ARE TE LATEST
NUMBERS WE HAVE. AND WHAT IS
THE PHONE NINE ASK. THE GOAL OF
PROJECT COME CHEAP THE CLIENT
YOU CAN. AND YOU JUMP TERMS OF
QUANTITY. OPEN TURN THE
QUANTITY WEALTH BECAUSE- MISTER
RESPONDED ON MENTION WE HAVE A
FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND FEDERAL FUNDS THAT
ADDITIONAL FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND YEAH SO.
WE'RE GONNA ATTEMPT. EIGHT CITY
A GOING TO BE ACCEPTING
APPLICATIONS FROM LOCAL THE
WORST PARTICIPATE AND ARE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND- TRY AND
APPROVED APPLIQUE SUCH A WAY
THAT WE'RE GOING TO MAXIMIZE
THE IMPACT ABOUT MONEY BUT IT.
THE POINT IN TIME IT'S
DIFFICULT TO SAY EXACTLY HOW
MANY UNITS WILL BE SECURE THAT
MONEY THANK YOU AND ONE OTHER
COM FOLLOW UP QUESTION. OF THE
A TEN. NOW A- WHY IS IT IS THAT
IS THAT THE END OF WHO BEEN
PLACED HOUSING OR IS THAT ROOMS
THAT HVE BEEN THAT ARE
AVAILABLE FOR HOUSING. THOSE
ARE- THOSE ARE OCCUPIED ROOMS
FOR RENT OFFICIALS. THANK YOU.
MR WILL NOT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR OF A I JUST WANT TO MAKE
A BRIEF COMMENT ABOUT THE
ALLOCATION OF THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE NATIONAL WHICH
MEANT MORTGAGE SHOW SPECIAL
DEPOSIT FUND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT. AND I'M VERY HAPPY TO SEE
JUST LIKE THE RESTORATION
TAKING ACTION ON THIS-
CERTAINLY IT'S GOING TO HELP.
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS IN
CALIFORNIA. I THINK EITHER
COMMENTS. ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
SINGLE PUBLIC COMMENT WAS MOVED
AB EIGHTY FOUR. SO EIGHTY
EIGHTY FOUR IS A TRAILER BILL
RELATED TO CALPERS AND CAL
STARS- AND BASICALLY- THE KEY
PROVISIONS OF THIS BILL- AND
MANY WAYS INTERACT WITH A
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT OF
THE TWENTY NINETY BUDGET ACT
HAD MADE A TWO POINT FIVE
BILLION OR SUPPLEMENTAL
PAYMENT. CALPERS AND SCHEDULED
FOR AND- ADDITIONAL SOME
PAYMENTS OVER THE THREE YEARS.
THAT DECISION WAS OF COURSE
MADE IN A VERY DIFFERENT FISCAL
ENVIRONMENT THAN THE ONE WE ARE
IN RIGHT NOW SO WHAT THIS
BUDGET DOES IS IT TAKES NEARLY
ALL THAT TWO POINT FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR PAYMENT. AND USES IT SEC
CALLOUSED. COPPERS CHANGE BOTH
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TWENTY WE DO
NOT MAKE THAT ARE NOT OUR-
THREE YEARS ANYMORE AT THE
FISCAL PRESSURES A NEED TO RE
DIRECT THAT TO A BASE
PRIORITIES IN ADDITION THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT HAD
PROVIDED TWO POINT THREE
BILLION DOLLARS TO WORD-
PENSION RELIEF LONG TERM FOR
SCHOOL EMPLOYERS THIS BILL RE
DIRECT THAT TO PROVIDE PENSION
RELIEF OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
YEARS- AND FINALLY THE- GET ONE
YEAR. ARE FREE WHEN IT COMES TO
A CONTRIBUTION ASTERS PLAN. MR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO ISN'T
DIVERTING THIS TWO AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS AWAY FROM- THE
PENSION SYSTEM GOING TO ROUTE
INCREASE THE LONG TERM-
UNFUNDED LIABILITY BUT THEN
THAT'S- SO IT IS THE CASE.
OBERNOLTE THAT- WITH THAT
PENSION CONTRIBUTION THE MORE
YOU PUT IT AT ANY LEVEL THE
MORE YOU PUT IN THE GREATER
YOUR SAVINGS ARE OVERTIME SO
ONE OF THE REASONS THE TWENTY
NINETEEN BUDGET ACT HAD MADE
THE SUPPLEMENTAL PAIN. IS TO
ACHIEVE THINGS TIME. CORRECT
THAT I SHOULD HOWEVER THAT
THESE PAYMENTS WERE ALWAYS
DESIGNED TO BE AND WORK A LOT
OF THE ACTUAR WE REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTION. TO THE STATE IS
NOT SO SPENDING IT'S REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTION THERE'S NO PENSION
HOLIDAY OF ANY TYPE THIS IS
SIMPLY SAYING THAT ARE MAKING
THE- VISION. TO MAKE BUT-
SHOULD NOT BE SHARES WERE NOT
PHYSICIAN TO MAKE THOSE RIGHT
NOW GIVEN THE NEED TO BALANCE
THE BUDGET. AND WHAT WOULD YOU
SAY THE- UNFUNDED LIABILITY IN
PERSON STIRS IS. SO I HAVE A
THE APPROXIMATE RANGE OF
FIGURES AND I ALSO HAVE EVELYN
SUITS ON THE PHONE- TO PROVIDE
MORE EXACT FIGURE BUT GENERALLY
IN TERMS OF RANGE AS- THE
STATE'S SHARE OF THE PERSONAL
LIABILITY. IS AROUND SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS I FOR CALLOUSED
ERRORS IT'S GENERALLY AROUND
THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS. SO WHEN
USED TO THE WORK IN THE ACTUAR
ONLY REQUIRED. CONTRIBUTIONS
YOU'RE REFERRING TO STATE LAW
NOT TO. THE NECESSITY OF
FUNDING THOSE PENSION SYSTEMS.
THAT IS CORRECT ALTHOUGH I WILL
SAY THAT THESE REQUIRED
CONTRIBUTIONS ALSO INCLUDE-
DOLLARS TO MAKE UP FOR THE
UNFUNDED LIABILITY THAT HAS
ACCRUED OVER TIME. I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T FALL TO SAID- YES SO-
WHEN AN UNFUNDED A LIABILITY-
DEVELOPS- THE STATUS IS
REQUIRED TO PAY THAT OFF OVER
TIME SO. THE CONTRIBUTIONS THAT
THE STATE MAKES ARE BOTH
CONTRIBUTIONS FOR THE NORMAL
COST OF PENSIONS- ADVERTISE
ALLEGATIONS IN THE PRESENT
YEAR- BUT ALSO CONTRIBUTIONS
FOR PASSED UNFUNDED LIABILITIES
NOW YOU CAN CERTAINLY MAKE AN
ARGUMENT THAT- STATES OR OTHER
JURISDICTIONS SHOULD BE MAKING.
THOSE PAYMENTS ON UNFUNDED
LIABILITIES MORE QUICKLY- BUT
THAT IS PART OF A CONTRIBUTION-
THAT'S REQUIRED OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ONCE.
QUESTIONS PUBLIC COMMENT ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. I SEE NO PUBLIC
COMMENT WAS MOVED AB AT IT.
EIGHTY EIGHTY EIGHT IS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY TRAILER BILL AND
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF DIFFERENT
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL SO LET
ME JUST MENTION A COUPLE VERY
BRIEFLY AND I'M HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS INCLUDING ON SOME
ELEMENTS THAT MAY NOT HAVE COME
UP- THE FIRST BASED ON A LOT OF
DISCUSSION WITH THE
LEGISLATURE- IS THE REQUIREMENT
FOR THE STATE TO IDENTIFY. A
STATE OWNED PRISON OFFICIALS
FOR CLOSER BOTH ON JANUARY
TENTH OF NEXT YEAR AND GENERATE
TEN A YEAR AFTER SO THAT'S THE
CURRENT PLAN WHICH TOLD TO
CLOSE THE STATE IT'S- OVER THE
NEXT SEVERAL YEARS. AT THIS
LAYS OUT WINDOWS PRESENCE NEED
TO BE IDENTIFIED FOR CLOSURE
AND WE HOPE IF THIS PROCESS.
INVOLVES BUT THAT WILL RESULT
IN SAVINGS FOR THE STATE. A
SECOND ITEM OF NOTE IS A BAND
THE BOX TYPE OF PROVISION FOR
POST SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS-
WHICH MEANS THAT. SHOULD NOT BE
ENQUIRING ABOUT CRIMINAL
HISTORY DURING THE OUT PATIENT
AND ADMISSIONS PROCESS- IT
WOULD STILL ALLOW. A-CONSIDERATION OF THAT HISTORY
AT BEFORE THE ENROLLMENT
DECISION IS MADE- BUT THIS IS
RELATED TO THE ADMISSIONS
APPLICATION PROCESS. IN IS THE
X. OF OUR COURT APPEARANCES
FOURTH AT BASED ON A LOT OF
DISCUSSION IS THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF NEW MAXIMUM TERM FOR PAROLE
FOR MOST OFFENDERS- AND THEN
FAITH IS. A DEFINITION. WHAT
CAUGHT IT'S AN S. TO REFLECT
THE STATE'S OUT ONCE. RULES
WORK OUR AT OR SALE ASSAULT
WEAPONS BUT HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS. MISERABLE TO THE SO
I UNDERSTAND HOW THE DEBATE
ABOUT CLOSING A STATE PRISON-
IS FISCAL AND I UNDERSTAND WHY
WERE HAVING THAT DISCUSSION IN
THE CONTEXT OF TALKING ABOUT
THE BUDGET BUT THE THINGS THAT
YOU DETAILS TO BE POLICY
CHANGES AND NOT BUDGETARY- SO
HOW ARE THINGS LIKE REDUCING
THE MAXIMUM LENGTH OF STAY TO
PRICE PAROLE. AUTHORIZING
MISDEMEANOR DIVERT OVER OVER
THE OBJECTION OF PROSECUTORS
EXPANDING THE EARLY RELEASE OF
CRIMINALS FROM STATE PRISONS
HOW HOW ARE THOSE- OF FISCAL
AND NOT POLICY AND WHY ARE WE
HAVING THOSE DISCUSSIONS NOW.
TRAILER BILL. THAN HAVING THOSE
BILLS TO SEE PROCESS. YES
MISTER OBERNOLTE UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE MAY BE DIFFERENCES
OF OPINION ON THIS- BUT FROM
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION WOULD YOU
BELIEVE THAT THESE- IMPLEMENT
THE BUDGET BELT- THEY ARE VERY
IMPORTANT AND RELATED TO.
PROVISIONS OF THE CHECK- AND
PART OF THE OVERALL FISCAL PLAN
AND WE BELIEVE IN MANY IF NOT
MOST OF THESE CASES OF THESE
PROVISIONS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED
AND DEBATED OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL MONTHS- SO WE DO
BELIEVE THAT THEY ARE PRO. FOR
INCLUSION HERE. WELL I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT AND I KNOW
THAT. A LOT OF PEOPLE. ON BOTH
SIDES OF THESE ISSUES HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT THE REASON
WHY WE HAVE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
IS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE THOSE
DEBATES IN A PUBLIC FORUM. AND
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT HERE WERE
RUSHING THROUGH THIS AND A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND I THINK
THAT'S- YOU KNOW VERY WERE.
THIS COOPER. THIS IS FOR
FINANCE- I THINK I'M GONNA HANG
ON THE LESS WE'RE JUST SAID
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE
ADMINISTRATION SO ONE OF THE
MOST MINUTE VERSION PROPOSAL
THIS INCLUDE THE FOLLOWING
CRIME ANNOYING OR MOLESTING A
CHILD POSITION IT'S NOT YOUR
FEE SEXUAL BATTERY. ONE WE'RE
STILL SIX OF THIS. TIER ONE
PRESIDENT. MISDEMEANOR CHILD
PORN ORAL COPULATION IN SEXUAL
BATTERY. CAN YOU WALK ME
THROUGH THE RATIONALE FOR
INCLUDING SEX CRIMES IS
ELIGIBLE FOR MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION. YES WHEN WE TURN IT
OVER AT WE HAVE BOTH CLICK CAL
ON AND ERIN EDWARDS ON THE
PHONE- WHEN WE TURN IT OVER TO
THEM TO SPEAK TO THAT. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ERIN I'VE
WORKED WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- WITH RESPECT TO. THOSE
PARTICULAR CATEGORY OF CRIME-
THEY I SUPPOSE COULD
POTENTIALLY BE ELIGIBLE FOR
THIS MISDEMEANOR PROGRAM IN THE
SENSE THAT. THE PROGRAM CREATE.
ARE A DIVERSION PROGRAMS. ANY
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSE- AND SO IN
THAT SENSE THEY COULD
POTENTIALLY BE ELIGIBLE NOW IN
TERMS OF THE RATIONALE FOR NOT
EXCLUDING PARTICULAR TYPES OF
CRIMES- THIS IS A LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL SO I CANNOT. SPEAK TO
THE THOUGHT PROCESS BEHIND
THAT- WHAT I CAN SAY IS THAT-
TO THE AT THE LEGISLATION
DOCTORS REQUIRE- JUDICIAL-
DISCRETION AND REVIEW- AND SO
IT WAS ANY CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH THEY JUDGE. HAD A
QUESTION OF WHETHER IT WAS A
PRO. YEAH BUT SOMEONE IN ONE OF
THE- HAVE IS THAT RIGHT. INTO
THE JUDGE COULD CERTAINLY BLOCK
THAT FROM. WELL YOU SAID
POTENTIALLY YOU IS THERE SO
THAT THAT'S WHEN THINGS THAT
WERE THE IS LEGISLATION WE'RE-
IT'S BEEN WRITTEN AND YOU HAVE
OF- APPLYING DONE IT SO. I HAVE
ISSUE WITH POTENTIALLY SO
EITHER IT IS OR ISN'T SUMMIT
TAKE THAT AS THEY ARE ELIGIBLE
CORRECT. THEY ARE ALL BOATS
PRACTICE IN AND WHAT'S THE
REASON BEHIND THAT AND I'LL PUT
TO SOMETHING WHEN DURING COLD
IN NINETEEN- THE SUPREME COURT
WAY THEN SAID WE'RE GONNA HAVE
NO BILL TO REDUCE POPULATIONS
FROM OUR JAILS AND- PRISONS.
BUT IF YOU LOOK AT IT CLOSELY.
THE SAME CHARGES THE SUPREME
COURT EXCLUDED. SO I MEAN THE I
THINK THEY SAW THE POTENTIAL
SOLVE THE ISSUES WITH IT AND
SOME THE PUBLIC OUTCRY SO THE
CHANGE FROM A LOST ANY POSITION
OF INCLUDING EVERYBODY AND- TO
EXEMPTING THESE FOLKS FROM
THIS. SO I'M TRYING TO
RATIONALIZE THAT AND CORRELATE
THE TWO. SURE SO AGAIN I. CAN'T
SPEAK FOR THE FOUGHT CROPPED UP
OF THE LEGISLATURE. THIS IS THE
SENATE PROPOSAL ON SO I DON'T
KNOW ALL OF THE- THOUGHT
PROCESS THAT WENT BEHIND IT BUT
I WOULD SAY. AGAIN THAT YOU
KNOW IN THOSE PARTICULAR
CATEGORIES THE DESCRIBING THE
JUDGE DOES HAVE THE DISCRETION
TO. PREVENT SOMEONE FROM
ENTERING INTO THIS PROGRAM. I
THINK THE BROADER RATIONALE.
GETTING THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
TO YOUR LEFT IS THAT. IT IS. IT
AN ATTEMPT TO SORT OF BREAK
BREAK THIS CYCLE OF CRIME- AND
ALLOW FOR THE DELIVERY OF
SERVICES OF REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS TO INDIVIDUALS.
OTHERWISE YOU KNOW MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO GET THE SERVICES THEY
NEED TO GET THEIR LIVES BACK ON
TRACK. CREATE OPPORTUNITY TO
REHABILITATE TOPS AND SO I
THINK THAT THAT WATER RATIONALE
FOR. CREATING THE PROGRAM TO BE.
THE BOTTOM LINE ADMINISTRATION
SUPPORTS IT SO THE SENATE MAY
HAVE. MANUFACTURED WELL WITH
THE MINISTRATIONS OF SAID WE A
BIG ISSUE WITH IT. WOULD SAY I
DON'T SEE ANY MY COLLEAGUES.
THE PUBLIC. TALKING ABOUT IN
SUPPORTING THESE FOR TOM LESS
SEXUAL BATTERY. IF YOU GRAB. IN
PRIVATE PLACES I'M THINGS LIKE
CHILD **** ORAL COPULATION
SEXUAL BATTERY I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY AND I SAID NO
CONSTITUENTS CALL ME AND
SUPPORTED GETTING FOLKS LIKE
THAT WITH THE MISDEMEANORS AND
ALSO WAS WHICH WAS TROUBLES AND
ALSO THIS IS ALSO FOR FINANCE.
IT TALKS ABOUT PROHIBITS
SECONDARY EDUCATION SO IF THIS
IS LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS SEE A LOT OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT TRAINING PROGRAMS
RUN THROUGH COLLEGES AND ONE
HERE SECOND RUN THROUGH COLLEGE.
APPLY AND THE WILL HAVE TO
REBUILD PAST HISTORY. THEY MAY
GRADUATE THAT LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING PROGRAM. AND THEN GET
HIRED IT MAY NOT BE THAT'S
BOSTON YU SEE THAT THAT RUNS
THAT PROGRAM GET HIRED BY
SOMEBODY ELSE. AND WHICH IS TO
GO TO WORK AS A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER. IN LIGHT OF WHAT'S
GOING ON TODAY I'M JUST
WONDERING FINANCE WHO WHO DO
THE RESEARCH ON THAT. AND DO
YOU SEE THAT AS A POTENTIAL
PROBLEM OCCURRING. THAT WE-
CHRIS FERGUSON I THE LINE WHO
ARE BEAR YOU CAN BEGIN ON. I
ACTUALLY THINK THAT ONE WILL
PROBABLY MORE APPROPRIATE FOR
EITHER CUENTA FOR PRESS. THIS
IS CHRIS FERGUSON BUT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I CAN-
FEEL THAT THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE
AROUND- ADMISSIONS AND NOT
ENQUIRING DOES NOT APPLY TO A
BASIC LAW ENFORCEMENT RANKING
PROGRAM SO. PROGRAM CONTINUE TO
BE ABLE TO PERFORM THOSE TRACKS.
OKAY. AND THEN ALSO JUST ONE
MORE THING ACTUALLY COUPLE MORE
THINGS- UNDER NUMBER TEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. GONNA
COMPASSIONATE RELEASE RIGHT NOW
THE BOARD OF FOR SOMEONE THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY GOING TO TAKE IT FROM
SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS THE BORDER
PATROLS ALWAYS BEEN INVOLVED IN
THIS BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY THEY GET
TO REVIEW THE PACKAGE THEY GOT
IN THE KNOWLEDGE AND DETAILS OF
WHAT THAT. PERSON'S HISTORY IS
AND WHAT THE THREAT IS WHAT IS
THE ADMINISTRATION'S RATIONALE
FOR REMOVING THE BOARD APPROVAL
FROM THAT PROCESS. ALL RIGHT.
YES BUT CALLEN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- THAT REMOVING THE
BOARD SEEMS LIKE- DUPLICATIVE
PROCESS- IT'S A CLINICIAN
MAKING A DETERMINATION ON
SOMEONE'S- LIKELY ARE ACTUALLY
HAVING A TERMINAL ILLNESS THAT
WAY THAT THEY'RE LIKE WOOD AND
WITHIN SIX MONTHS ORIGINALLY
NOW BEING MOVED TO TWELVE
MONTHS- THAT IS SORT OF THE
MARKER FOR THAT AND THAT ALWAYS
GOES TO THE SECRETARY FOR
DECISION AND THEN DOCTOR
REFERRED TO THE COURT- FOR
FINAL DETERMINATION SO IT
DIDN'T FEEL LIKE- THE BOARDS-
INPUT IN THAT PROCESS WAS
PARTICULARLY VALUABLE- GIVEN
THAT ULTIMATELY THE COURT THAT
MAKES A DECISION. AND IF THE
CLINICIAN MAKING THAT
DETERMINATION ARE UNDERLYING
HEALTH CONDITION THAT MAKES
THEM ELIGIBLE YOU TALK ABOUT
CLINICIAN BUT THE BOARD IT'S
BEEN IN EFFECT FOR I DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY NUMBER OF YEARS IN THE
BEEN AFFECTED WITH THAT SO I'M
IF THIS REASON IF THAT WAS TO
BE A BETTER PROCESS WITH THAT I
AND I'M A- PASSED NEARLY. BUT
ONE MAKE SURE THAT THE END OF
THE DAY NUMBER ONE IS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY IS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY IS ASSURED AND I THINK
BY HAVING POWER MANY DAYS THIS
IS THE PLACE TO ASSESS IT WORK
BUT I'M GOT THAT. ALSO IN WHEN
THE AGE. WHAT DO THE- YES THERE
IS AN EXPANSION TO THE ELDERLY
PRO PROGRAM I THINK. THE BAY.
TWENTY IN YOUR HEIRS OF PARKER
CENTER HERE'S A- TWENTY EIGHT
YEARS CARS ARE THAT THAT MAY
SOMEONE A LEGIT FOR LIFE FOR
SUITABILITY AND- I AS YOU OF
STATE THAT THE VERY. OF
RGOROUS PROCESS THAT CLINICAL
RESEARCH. BANDS BUT COMMITTEE
REVIEW. INCLUDE THE A- VICTIM
PARTICIPATION- AND THOSE THAT
ARE RELEASED TO THAT PROPER
TIME INCREDIBLY LOW RECIDIVISM
RATE I THINK IT'S AROUND. 224%
AND EVEN THOUGH THAT RISK.
RIGHT RIGHT NOW THE VICTIM BUT
I I'M NOT I MAY DISAGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING VICTIMS DON'T.
THE WAY THE WAY IT IS RIGHT NOW
VICTIMS DON'T HAVE A SAY SO IN
SOME OF THESE ISSUES WITH THAT.
I BELIEVE THERE'S NOTIFICATION
AND- AND THE ABILITY FOR THEM
TO PROVIDE INPUT- ON THAT. IN
INTO THOSE HEARINGS- BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU KNOW
THERE'S ALWAYS- TWO SIDES TO
EVERY DISCUSSION. BUT THAT
PROCESS HAS BEEN SHOWN TO BE.
YOU KNOW A GOOD WAY TO MAKE
RELEASED DECISIONS FOR PEOPLE
THAT ARE INCARCERATED. OKAY
THANK YOU IT WAS REPORTED.
THANK YOU THAT MR TRIES WHEN I
ASK ABOUT TO. TWO ISSUES THAT I
WAS TRYING TO PULL UP THE
ACTUAL BILL RIGHT HERE AND I
COULDN'T GET IN TIME BUT ONLY
NOW SAYS ABOUT THIS WHOLE BAND
THE BOXING THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT I'M- NOT FAMILIAR WITH
THAT WROTE THAT BAN THE BOX
LAWYER TWO YEARS AGO FOR
EMPLOYMENT AND MY
UNDERSTANDING- OF HOW IT'S
BEING IMPLEMENTED. IS THAT THE
INITIAL APPLICATION. FOR YOU
CAN'T ASK THE QUESTION BUT-LATER ON IN THE PROCESS YOU CAN
YOU CAN INQUIRE ONCE THERE'S A
CONDITIONAL JOB OFFER MADE SO
THAT SAME PRINCIPLE APPLIED
HERE TO THE- TO THE THIS CALL
IS OBLIGATION PROCESS WHERE THE
INITIAL- PIECE WOULD BE
PROHIBITED BUT TO BE LATER DOWN
THE ROAD BEFORE THE FINAL
DECISION. THERE WERE THERE
WOULD BE. THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
MY MISSING SOMETHING YES
SOMEONE MEMBER MCCARTY AND I'LL
CHRIS ON THE LINE TO PROVIDE
ANY DETAIL BUT BASICALLY THE
WAY IT'S WRITTEN IS A SIMILAR
PROCESS AND THAT- THE POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS TO WHICH
THIS PROVISION IS APPLICABLES
WHEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER
SAID DISCUSSION THAT'S NOT
EVERY SINGLE INSTITUTION THERE
ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS BUT TO
THOSE INSTITUTIONS WERE IT IS
APPLICABLES COULD BE BY OUR
TACTIC GENERATION FOR
ADMISSIONS DECISIONS OUT THAT
YES OR NO ON THE ADMISSIONS-
CANNOT CONSIDER- SOMEONE'S
CRIMINAL BACKGROUND HISTORY
HOWEVER BEFORE THAT INDIVIDUAL
IS ABLE TO ENROLL. YOU SHOULD
IF IT WERE. CAN'T BETTER THAT
HISTORY BEFORE MAKING AT
ACTUALLY. DECISION FOR THE STEW
TO BE IN THE SCHOOL- BUT LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO CHRIS TO
PROVIDE ANY OTHER DETAILS. YEAH
I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT TO
DURING THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS
THEY WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO HAVE
THAT QUESTION OR ASK FOR YOU TO
LIKE THAT INFORMATION. BUT
PRIOR TO STUDENT IN ROLLING
THEY CERTAINLY. I WOULD BE ABLE
TO CHAT- AND THEN ALSO I NEED
TO DO SHE WOULD NOT BE
PROHIBITED FROM VERY CLEARLY
AND ALL OF THEIR- OUTREACH
MATERIALS TO STUDENTS AND IN
ADMISSIONS MATERIALS TO
STUDENTS. WOULD BE ABLE TO
OUTLINE. YOU'VE GOT A DIFFERENT
YOU KNOW LIKE THE TO
REQUIREMENTS THINGS THE
DISTRICT MUST- BE ABLE TO OR
MUST BE AWARE OF. OR MADE AWARE
OF BIGGER WILL. ASK DURING.
THANK YOU. SIMILAR TO WHAT WE
DO WITH OUR AND EMPLOYMENT
BOXING THE CRATES A SECOND
OPPORTUNITY TO WEED OUT
INDIVIDUALS AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THIS WOULD BE
HELPFUL IF SOMEONE APPLIES WITH
MINOR DRUG OFFENSE OR D. Y. AT
THE AT THE OUTSET AND THEN
MAYBE THERE WASN'T THE KIND OF
PRIVATE FIRST PLACE BUT IF THEY
HAVE. SERIOUS OFFENSE LIKE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OR THE WAR
SOME TYPE THAT YOU KNOW SERIOUS
BATTERY- LATER BEFORE THEY
ACTUALLY DO THE ENROLLMENT YOU
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EXCLUDE THOSE THOSE INDIVIDUALS
IT IS THAT THE RATIONALE. FOR
THE SOLE POLICY. IT TOO TO NOT-
PUSH AWAY INDIVIDUALS WITH
MAYBE MINOR. INFRACTIONS WHEN
THEY LOOK TO. APPLY FOR SUCH
PROGRAMS. YES GENERALLY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY AT THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES THAT
THIS IS PART OF A BROADER SHIFT
I THINK WE ARE SEEING IN THE
CONVERSATION IN THIS AREA- THAT
PART OF REHABILITATION- IS
MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO
HAVE PASSED INVOLVEMENT WITH
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
ONE ELEVEN BETTER LIVES HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO SO-
WITHOUT BEING-
DISPROPORTIONATELY TREATED
BASED ON SOMETHING THAT THEY
MAY HAVE DONE IN THE PAST SO AS
YOU NOTED- THIS DOESN'T BAR THE
CONSIDERATION OF BACKING ATION
BUT- WE HOPE THAT IT ENCOURAGES
INSTITUTIONS- TO FOR ABOUT.
REST OF A PERSON'S RECORD-
BEFORE INCLUDING THAT OTHER ACT
FROM THE BACKGROUND BUT HERE
SHE MAY HAVE SO JUST TO MAKE US
MORE COMFORTABLE BEFORE THERE'S
AN ACTUAL ROLE MEANT IF IT SO I
FOUND OUT THAT INDIVIDUAL WHO
DIDN'T ANSWER YET L. CATION
CODE IS NOT. HAS THAT HIS OF
SERIOUS TO MASS VIOLENCE
ASSAULT AND BATTERY WOULD HAVE
YOU. THAT'S THE TIME WHERE THE
INSTITUTION WOULD WOULD MOST
LIKELY. DID DENY THE INDIVIDUAL
FROM FROM PROCEEDING WITH THE-
EDUCATION PROGRAM SEKARANG.
THEY WOULD HAVE THE DISCRETION
TED TO MAKE A DECISION THERE
YEAH WELL IS THAT THE INTENT
THAT YOU WOULD BE THAT THERE
WOULD BE- THAT WE WOULD WAIT
OUT IN THE INSTITUTIONS OF WEED
OUT INDIVIDUALS. CANCERS THAT
TIME. I SAID THAT ESPECIALLY IN
THE CASES WHERE THIS IS
APPLYING TO PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS- I
DON'T THINK THE STATE IS IN A
POSITION TO DETERMINE- WHICH-
WHICH PARTS OF A PERSON'S
CRIMINAL HISTORY SHOULD BE
DISQUALIFIED. VERSUS NOT AT YOU
EVEN THAT YOU CAN SEE VERY
SCENARIOS IT'S ALL BASED ON
CONTACT- BUT TO YOUR POINT THAT
INSTITUTION WOULD BE ABLE TO
DECIDE FOR ITSELF IN MAKING THE
WRONG DECISION. WHICH FACTORS-
TO WHITE. SO THIS IS FOR ALL
I'M I'M TOTALLY CONFUSED NO
THIS IS NOT FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING PROGRAMS IT'S FOR. ALL
HIGHER EDUCATION ENROLLMENT I
SHOULD CLARIFY NAMED CHRIS CAN
WEIGH IN A IT APPLIES TO A
NUMBER OF POST SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS- BUT WITH
EXCEPTIONS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING THERE ALSO EXCEPTIONS
RELATED TO PROFESSIONAL SCHOOLS
SUCH AS IN A LAW SCHOOL THESE
ARE GOVERNED BY THEIR OWN SET
OF STANDARDS AND THEYHAVE OWN
GUIDELINES BUT LET ME TURN IT
OVER TO CHRIS TO DESCRIBE THAT
THE DIFFERENT PERMUTATIONS. BUT
CERTAINLY IF YOU DON'T APPLY TO
ALL OF THE STATE. INSTITUTIONS
WHETHER THEY'RE PUBLIC OR
PRIVATE- WHAT I WOULD SAY IS
WITH UNDERGRADUATE ADMISSIONS
SPECIFICALLY. AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. A LARGELY
DO NOT AFFECT QUESTION ON THEIR
ADMISSIONS APPLICATIONS TODAY.
SO THERE THERE IS NO IMPACT ON
THAT SIDE OF THE EQUATION. FOR
UNDERGRADUATE ADMISSIONS I
THINK THAT THE THIRD STILL USE
OF A COMMON APPLICATION AND
MANY PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS THAT
DON'T HAVE THAT QUESTION ON
THAT- IN BOTH INSTITUTIONS
WOULD HAVE ONE YEAR TO. ALTER
THEIR PROCESS AND THEIR
APPLICATION TO NOT CONSIDER
THAT AS PART OF THE NATION'S
BUT CERTAINLY THEY CAN DO THAT
AS PART OF ENROLLMENT. BUT THE
SORT OF LARGER- DISCUSSION THAT
WE'VE HEARD. IS MOST OF THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE
ENTERING A PROGRAM THROUGH
WHICH THEY CAN'T OBTAIN LICENSE
FOR AT THE END- AND I THINK ON
THE FRONT AND SORT OF THE
RATIONALE THAT WE'VE HEARD. YES
IT IS- LIMITING A CYCLE COMPARE
YOUR TO STUDENTS WHO ARE IN
THAT SITUATION THEY BEGIN A
CAJUN TO. SEEK ADMITTANCE TO AN
INSTITUTION- BUT THEY THEY
STOP. A PAST THAT QUESTION AND
THEY FAILED TO COMPLETE THEIR
APPLICATION- FOR CONSIDERATION
TO THE INSTITUTION I THINK
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS
LANGUAGE IS FOCUSED ON THE-
SHORTER MOVE MATT BEAR KIRK ON
THE FRONT END OF APPLYING BUT
STILL UNABLE. TO JUSHIN TO MAKE
SURE. THAT THOSE STUDENTS WHO
BE ABLE TO. IN ANY PROFESSIONAL
STANDARDS ARE CONTROL. THE
GIVEN WITH HER FOR ONCE THE
IGNITION. A BEEN MADE. AND ALSO
OUR INSTITUTIONS WERE BE ABLE
TO CHECKS FOR THINGS LIKE.
HOUSING AND ON IT SERVE ONE
TAKES STUDENT. HAS ADMIT FOR
THE MOST ARE PER BEACHES. I DO
TRACKS AT THE BEGIN TO. DEVELOP
ON EDUCATIONAL PLAN WITH EACH
STUDENT AS THEY- SAY- YOU KNOW
SEEK TO. OUR DRIVE TO WORK FOR
THAT PARTICULAR- MAJOR WAR
PARTICULAR PROGRAM LOOK AT
INDIVIDUAL COURSES SO IT'S
REALLY DONE AS PART OF THOSE
EDUCATIONAL YOUR PLANS FOR
STUDENTS FOR THE MOST PART.
THAT THAT WHEN YOU TRY TO
CHECKS WOULD. ARE TRADITIONALLY
CAR AT MANY OF THE INSTITUTIONS.
SO TO CONFIRM TO THAT TO
CONFIRM IS NOT. MAINLY FOR YOU
SEE THIS IS NOT REALLY AT ALL
FOR OUR PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
COMMITTEE COLLEGES SEE IS HERE
YOU SEE YOU DON'T ASK THE
QUESTION AT ALL BUT FOR MORE OF
THE- PRIVATE ATTENSITY THE FOR
PROFIT COLLEGES. WE SHOULD GIVE
THEM A GOOD UC AND CSU AND
COMMUNICATIVE ANYWAY MUCH
CHEAPER- ANOTHER ISSUE- JUST
REAL QUICK I WANTED TO ASK
ABOUT THE-THE PAROLE OVER FOR
THEM PROPOSAL WHEN IT WAS
PROPOSED IN IN MAY- THERE IS
SOME LEGISLATIVE CONCERNED
THAT- IN CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS.
WHO HAD SEX OFFENSES WHETHER
THEY'RE THEY'RE REGISTERED TO
NINETY IN THE IDOLS OR OR- IN
IN THAT- IN THAT VICINITY.
THERE IS A THERE IS A FEW
CATEGORIES THAT WERE AND THEY
WERE NEGLECTED IN THE MAY
PROPOSAL AND THOSE ARE SAYING
THAT WAS GOING TO BE- TIGHTENED
UP IN ADDRESSED. HERE AND I
HEARD THAT QUESTION FROM MY-
COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE. AND
I'M AS WELL TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE DID- DO THAT WHAT WE HAD
pLITTLE BIT CONFUSED ON THIS NEW
ISSUE THAT WAS RAISED BY. BY
BUT BUT MISTER COOPER HAVE YOU
CAN HELP ME HERE. YES WHEN WE
TURN IT OVER JACQUELINE CALLUM
AND ALSO AIRED EDWARDS ON THE
PHONE. AT THE ORIGINAL- PAROLE
REFORM PROPOSAL IN THE MAYOR
VISION AND- ALLOWED OR-
SHORTENED TERM BEEN A DISCHARGE
REVIEW PROCESS FOR- PENAL CODE
TO NINETY REGISTRANTS- THAT HAD
BEEN EXCLUDED- FROM THE FINAL
BUDGET AND I HAVE RELATED
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE. THAT HOW
DOES THAT RELATE TO THE TO THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT- MISTER COOPER
NOTED ARE NOW. ELIGIBLE TO
PARTICIPATE IN SOME OTHER.
ELEMENT TO THIS TRAILER BILL.
YEAH THOSE ARE TWO ENTIRELY
DIFFERENT PROGRAMS THAT ONCE
THAT AGENT ROLE REFORM OKAY
I'LL I'LL I'LL PACK BUT TO. MY
COLLEAGUE. SO THE PROGRAM THAT
MISTER COOPER WAS REFERRING TO
IS- MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION
PROGRAM- TO THAT THAT SEPARATE
PROGRAM THAT'S CREATED TO
ALLOW- AT THE DISCRETION OF THE
JUDGE- THE- ADMISSION OF-
SOMEONE HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH A
MISDEMEANOR. INTO A DIVERSION
PROGRAM WHERE BY THAT
INDIVIDUAL CAN PARTICIPATE.
WIRED WE BOTH STATION
PROGRAMMING AB ON THE
SATISFACTORY COMPLETION OF THAT
PROGRAMMING- THE COURT CAN
DISMISS THE UNDERLYING OFFENSE.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU. MISS
COOPER THE FULL QUESTION THANK
YOU MISTER THIS NOTHING TALKED
ABOUT THE ADMINISTRATION HAS
THE DISEASE LOW LEVEL OFFENSES
SO AND MIKE WANTED UNDERSTAND
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
CONSIDERS. OVERPOPULATION A LOW
LEVEL OFFENSE SOCIAL BATTERY
LOW LEVEL OFFENSE. SO WHEN WE
WILL MAKE COLLEGE SANTA THAT IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE OVERALL
PROGRAM. NOT ALL THE GUTS AS
NOTHING MORE QUESTIONS SO WITH
THE VERSION IT CAN BE GRANTED
OVER THE OBJECTION OF A DA. AND
SO SOME OF THE ISSUES WITH- DO
YOU LIVE OBVIOUSLY MULTIPLE DO
YOU EYES WITH PRIORS INCLUDING
FELONIES- CAN BE DIVERTED HIS
AS WELL FOR DIVERSION. PHILLIES
MESSICK VIOLENCE WITH THE PRIOR
AND WE KNOW DURING THE CALL THE
NINETEEN OTHER MISS CAUCUS HE
MISSTATED THE NUMBER TO MISTER
LOT OF CASES WHEN OF
DRAMATICALLY. AND ALSO CHILD
pSO THEY CAN BE DIVERTED AND IF
THAT INDIVIDUAL DOES NOT WANT
TO REVEAL THEIR RECORD THEY
DON'T HAVE TO SO LET'S SAY-
THESE CRIMES RIGHT NOW THAT ARE
IN THIS. TODAY'S BILL WE'RE
GONNA HEAR ONE O'CLOCK. IN THE
SEXUAL BATTERY ORAL COPULATION
IF THE VERDICT INCOMPLETE
DIVERSION AND MIND YOU KNOW THE
VERSION. IS CAN BE ANYTHING
INCLUDING JUST PICKING UP TRASH
ON THE WEEKENDS. NOT SKINNER
BECAUSE YOU WENT THROUGH A
COURSE OF SEX OFFENDERS COURSE
BUT- TAKING UP TRASH ON A WORK
PROJECT. SO YOU COMPLETE THAT.
YOU GET DIVERTED. YOU APPLY FOR
A JOB AS A MASSAGE THERAPIST
MAYBE OR A SCHOOL YARD DUTY.
THAT IS EXPUNGED FROM RECORD.
SO HOW DOES THE ADMINISTRATION.
WRAP THEIR ARMS AROUND THAT ONE.
YES THIS IS A NET IN A CONTEXT
OF THE OVERALL REHABILITATION
EVER BUT WHEN WE SPEAK OUT WHEN
WE TURN OVER TO CLICK HERE TO
SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO BE
EXAMPLES YOU MUCH. THE FOR
THEIR NETWORK SO I THINK- AS I
UNDERSTAND YOUR QUESTION
CORRECTLY- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COOPER THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
THE MISDEMEANOR DIVERSION
PROGRAM IN PARTICULAR. CORRECT
ENOUGH SO I THINK- ARE VETO HE
IS THAT THE IN THE IN THOSE
SORTS OF CIRCUMSTANCES I THINK.
THE JUDGE WOULD- NOT OFFER
DIVERSION IT AGAIN IT IS UP TO
THE JUDICIAL DISCRETION SO BUT
YOU THINK I. KNOW WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT EXCUSE ME. YOU THINK. NOT
CUT IT THAT DOES NOT OKAY
THAT'S NOT SEPTIMAL. YOU THINK.
IT'S UP TO A JUDGE'S DISCRETION
THAT AS A HUMAN BEING YOU'RE
DOING WITH THEIR DISCRETION A
JUDGE CAN DO ANYTHING AND WE
SAW THE BROCK TURNER CASE AND
STAND FOR THE STANFORD RATE
CASE. JUDGES MAKE MISTAKES. SO
I MEAN YOU THINK DOES NOT CUT
IT. SO IT A LOT THIS CUTTING
SPELLED OUT IN THE LAW WHAT IS
ALLOWABLE WAS NOT ALLOWABLE
THAT'S NOT OKAY SO I MEAN FOR
YOU TELL ME YOU THINK. THAT
THAT'S NOT GOOD LAW. NOT A GOOD
PRACTICE. WELL I THINK I WOULD
JUST SIMPLY SAY THAT IN THIS.
IN THIS PARTICULAR PROGRAM- THE
JUDGE DOES HAVE DISCRETION IN
TERMS OF COULD A LOT AND THEY
ARE GENERALLY CONSIDERED TO BE
IMPARTIAL OUR BURGERS AND-
ACCEPTING WHAT IS IN THE
INTEREST OF JUSTICE AND SO. SO
THE JUDGE AS THOSE ARE. PART OF
A NAKED CERTAINLY BLOCK THM
NOT TRAIN BUT BUT IF SOMEBODY
IF SOMEBODY GETS DIVERSION. AND
THEY COULD BE DIFFERENT THAN.
THEY DON'T HVE TO REVEAL THEIR%
RECORDS SO. IN MY IN MY
INCORRECT THAT THEY GO OUT AND
BE A YARD DUTY A YARD ONDER TO
SCHOOL FOR MASSAGE THERAPIST.
AM I INCORRECT IN THAT
ASSUMPTION THEN. I DON'T I
CAN'T ANSWER THAT QUESTION I
DON'T HAVE THOSE SORTS OF
DETAILS- I WOULD HAVE TO GET
BACK TO YOU IN TERMS OF WHAT-
SECONDARY PROBE PROHIBITIONS
WHAT APPLY. THOSE SORT OF WILL
NOT TO VOTE ON HOW. NOT TO VOTE
ON THIS AND- A COUPLE HOURS I
MEAN IT HERE WE ARE. AND YOU
GUYS ARE ATTORNEYS OR WHOEVER
YOU GOT TO DEFEND THIS ALREADY.
I MEAN THIS IS THE IT IS IT'S A
BAD BILL IS AS- MY COLLEAGUE
FROM BIG BEAR SAID EARLIER.
THIS SHOULD EARN A POLICY
COMMITTEE NOT A TRAILER BILL.
THAT WE DON'T KNOW THESE THINGS
THIS THIS IS CRITICAL AND I GOT
A KID I'M FOUR DAUGHTERS AND
THESE NUMBERS APPEAR HAVE KIDS
GRANDKIDS NIECES AND NEPHEWS.
THIS IS UNACCEPTABLE TRISHA
THIS STUFF THROUGH AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHAT THE WE'RE- PUBLIC.
DOES IT GIVE A- HECK ABOUT
CHILD MOLESTERS PEOPLE THAT
BEAT THEIR SPOUSES. THAT ARE
INVOLVED IN CHILD **** THERE'S
ONE ADVOCATING FOR THEM OUT
HERE INNATE LET'S WILL HAVE QUE
FOR THESE FOLKS THEY DON'T THEY
DON'T GET A BREAK. SO THIS IS
JUST I'M NOT. THIS IS CRAZY NOW
WE'RE THIS IS UP HERE TODAY.
AND STAFF FINANCE. DOESN'T KNOW
THE DETAILS THE BILL THERE'S
LITTLE TO FIND OUT UNACCEPTABLE.
GOING TO MISTER FOR. I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR- ON WHAT MY
COLLEAGUE FROM ELK GROVE HAS
STATED IF THEY HAVE AN
INDIVIDUAL FINISHES AND A
DIVERSION PROGRAM ARE THE IS
THEIR RECORD EXPUNGED. YES THEY
COMPLETE THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
ANOTHER WHAT THEY GO THROUGH
THE REQUIRED WE HAVE PUT IN A
PROGRAMS- COMPLETE ALL THE
CONDITIONS IMPOSED BY THE
COURT- THE COURT CAN DISMISS
THAT UNDERLYING CHARGE. OKAY SO
THE SO THE RECORD IS AT THAT
POINT CLEARED. YES I BELIEVE
DECLARED. SO THE SCENARIO THAT
MY COLLEAGUE OUTLINED IS
POSSIBLE WHERE IF SOMEONE WERE
TO FINISH IT IN EXPLAINS A
RECORD THAT THAT WAY IF THEY
WERE TO APPLY FOR. ANY ANY JOB
AND IN REGARDS TO WEAR THEM
THAT. THAT THEY THAT THAT WOULD
NOT BE ON THE RECORD. I'M
RESEARCHING THIS PARTICULAR
QUESTION RIGHT NOW I WILL GET
BACK TO YOU VERY SHORTLY WITH
AN ANSWER TO SAY THE ABS I'M
SORRY TO HEAR THAT. I AM
LOOKING INTO THIS ISSUE AT THE
MOMENT I CAN GET BACK TO YOU
VERY SHORTLY AFTER. OKAY WELL
WE WILL WE GET AN ANSWER BY ONE
O'CLOCK LEGAL. ABSOLUTELY RIGHT
THANK YOU. SO WHAT I HAVE A
COUPLE QUESTIONS TERM FINANCE
ON CAN YOU. DISCUSS THE BAND A
BOX PROGRAMS WERE AND HOW IT
ENTER WORLDS WITH LAST YEAR'S
BUDGET APPROPRIATION FOR
PROJECT REBOUND. WHICH WAS A
PROGRAM THAT WE FIND IT AT NINE
CAL STATE SCHOOLS. LET ME TRY
IT YES I TURN IT OVER TO CHRIS
FERGUSON TO DISCUSS THAT. I.
THINK THE WAY THAT THIS-
BANDBOX LANGUAGE COULD
ACTUALLY- YOU KNOW WE'D VERY
NICELY WITH. A PROJECT REBOUND
GET THAT ADDS MORE STUDENTS
APPLYING AND FINISH THEIR
APPLICATIONS THAT MIGHT BE IN
THIS. IN A GIVEN SITUATION AND
I CAN SAY A CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY. THEY WOULD THEN AT
THE AT THE EDUCATIONAL MASTER
PLANS ARE WORKED OUT BETWEEN
EACH STUDENT. AND THEIR
COUNSELOR THE COUNCIL WOULD BE
ABLE TO DETERMINE THAT THE
STUDENT IS IN THIS SITUATION
AND HELP THEM GET. YOU SET
PROJECT REBOUND IN THE SERVICES
THAT ARE PROVIDED BY PROJECT
REBOUND- WHICH IS. FOR THE
LARGE PART AS WE LEARNED LAST
YEAR I'VE BEEN VERY SUCCESSFUL
IN HELPING FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS
COMPLETE A BACHELOR'S DEGREE
PROGRAMS AT THE CSC. THANK YOU.
JUST GOING BACK TO THE- PAROLE
QUESTION- WE TALKED ABOUT THIS
THE ELDER PAROLE CAN YOU TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE FISCAL
PETITIONS REGARDING THE- PAROLE
POLICY. IN TERMS OF POTENTIAL
COST SAVINGS. YES. YET AT GOING
CALLUM AGAIN- SO THERE'S TWO
MAIN COMPONENTS THERE'S THE
PAROLE- REFORMS THAT WERE
INCLUDED IN THE MAYOR OF
BEIJING AND WHICH SHORTEN TERMS
FOR CERTAIN PAROLEES THAT ALLOW
FOR AND- AND EARNED DISCHARGE
PROCESS FOR THOSE WITHOUT- ANY
VIOLATION ON THEIR PAROLE
PERIOD- THAT EXPECTED TO SAVE
ABOUT TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS IN THE BUDGET YEAR
GROWING TO SIXTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS BY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR- ADVOCATING TDK ARE MUCH
MUCH OF THEIR COSTS ARE DRIVEN
BY THE POPULATION THAT ARE
EITHER IN THE INSTITUTION AND
THAT PROVIDING HOUSING
TREATMENT OR REHABILITATION YOU
ARE SUPERVISING IN THE
COMMUNITY SO HERE AS WE- AT
SHRINK THE PAROLE. TO ME. UP
WITH THAT MùT PEOPLE ARE SO
TO BE IN THE YEAR THIS DOES
GENERATE I'M QUITE A BIT A
GENERAL FUND PAVING. AND THEN
THE EXPANSION OF ELDERLY
PAROLE- WE EXPECT TO GENERATE-
SOMEWHERE IN THERE AND THE NET
NEIGHBORHOOD OF HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
POTENTIALLY GOING TO MILLION.
IN THE OUT YEARS- AS YOU
COMPARE THE COURT THE COST OF
THE NATIONAL SUITABILITY
HEARINGS VERSUS THOSE RELEASED-
BUT AGAIN THAT THAT THE GENERAL
FUND SAVING AND AN AREA WHERE.
THE PEOPLE TEND TO HAVE A
REALLY LOW RECIDIVISM LEVEL.
THANK YOU CAN YOU CAN YOU ALSO
ADDRESS FOR COST SAVINGS.
THROUGH THE MISDEMEANOR
DIVERSION POLICY AS WELL. TO OR
ANY POTENTIAL COST SAVINGS.
THERE ARE NOT WORDS IN TERMS OF
THE COST SAVINGS UP WE HAVEN'T
SCORED ANYTHING SPECIFICALLY
AND THE BUDGET- I THINK THE
THERE ARE POTENTIAL. SAVINGS
DOWN THE LINE TO THE EXTENT
THAT- A LOT OF TIMES WHAT WE
SEE IS PEOPLE WHO CYCLE THROUGH
MISDEMEANOR OFFENSIVE- AND
SOMETIMES LOWER LEVEL OFFENSIVE
DO AT SOME POINT TO PROGRESS TO
THE POINT WHERE DID YOU COMMIT
MORE SERIOUS OFFENSES THEY
DON'T GET. REHABILITATIVE
SERVICES AND SO- I THINK IF TO
THE EXTENT INDIVIDUALS GO INTO
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ABLE TO- GET
REHABILITATIVE SERVICES AND
REDUCE RECIDIVISM THERE COULD
BE SOME DOWNSTREAM SAVINGS- IN
TERMS OF. FUTURE REDUCTION
FUTURE PRESENT COMMITMENTS- BUT
THAT IS. SOMEWHAT BACK WHAT IS
IT SO WE HAVE AN SCHOOL
ANYTHING IN THE BY SHOULD THAT
OCCUR IT WOULD GET PICKED
PICKED UP AT SEVEN LATER WHEN
WE DO OUR ANNUAL ADJUSTMENTS-
BASED ON THE PRISON POPULATION.
OKAY THANK THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE TALKED WEBER. I WANT
TO- FIRST WHAT I'M AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT STAFF IS DONE AND I THINK-
SOMETIMES WE LOOK AT THESE-
PROPOSALS AND UNFORTUNATELY-
DUE TO TIME CONSTRAINTS WE HAD
WE HAVE NOT HAD AN OPPORTUNITY
TO HAVE MUCH DISCUSSION IN THE
UNIVERSE OF COMMITTEES ON THESE
ISSUES AND SO THAT'S THE
IMPORTANT PIECE. I KIND OF
UNDERSTAND MOST OF IT BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT MANY OF THESE
HAVE BEEN STE RECYCLED THROUGH
THE HOUSE AT SOME POINT IN SOME
PROXY OR SOME BUILD UP THERE
BUT- IT'S UNFORTUNATE NOT HAD
ENOUGH NEEDED MORE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THE THINGS THAT WE HEAR
IN THIS PACKAGE TO. IT DOESN'T
WITH THAT'S BEEN BREACHED BY
THE THREE D. SO IT'S DIFFICULT
TO SAY- I UNDERSTAND AND THE
BOX ANDI THINK IT IS IMPORTANT.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND I THINK
SOMETIMES WE GET CONCERNED BUT
THE REALITY IS IT DOES EXIST IN
OUR BIG SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE
THE UC'S IN THE C. ISSUES DON'T
ASK THESE QUESTIONS AND THE N.
AS HAVING BEEN A PROFESSOR I'VE
HAD A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
ACTS OF IS IN CLASSES WORKING
ON A GREAT DEGREE. AND I'VE IN
CURRENT THEY WILL IMPROVE THE
THAT THEY WANTED TO DO BETTER
BECAUSE IT'S NOT AN EASY THING
TO FOR SEE. AND GO THROUGH ALL
THAT WORKING HARD WORK IS THERE
BECAUSE SOME OF THEM DON'T
QUALIFY FOR CERTAIN FINANCIAL
AID AND ON AND ON AND ON AND SO
IT'S BILLION CARDS WHEN. WHEN I
THE STUDENTS WHO HAVE. GONNA
THE WRONG PATH AND COME BACK
AND NOW THEY HAVE TO UNIVERSE.
EARNING DEGREES AND SOME OF MY
STE. AND NOW. TO A ONCE IN.
WERE PROFESSOR AND HAD. A REAL
CHALLENGES WHEN THEY WERE
EIGHTEEN AND NINETEEN YEARS OLD
AND A FIVE SIX SEVEN YEARS IN
PRISON. AND COME BACK AND
DECIDE TO GO TO THE IN THE
FAMILY THAT ARE GOING TO
REBUILD A LIFE. DONE IT. AND
OUR REAL CREDIT TO THE
COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THEY WORK
IN. A SOCIAL WORKERS AND
BUSINESS OWNERS AND WHAT HAVE
YOU SO. IT IS IT IT YOU KNOW I
THINK YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
REHABILITATION WE HAVE TO TALK
ABOUT ALL. AND I THINK. ONE OF
OUR KIDS WHO'VE BEEN
STREAMLINED COME I DON'T FIRST
WOULD BE HAPPY. WE HATE TO HAVE
THE NOT AN OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND UNIVERSITY BECAUSE- THEY
HAD A PRIOR. BETTER SO ARE YOU
KNOW THAT'S IMPORTANT INVESTED
AT TO ALWAYS REMEMBER BE. WE
SAY WE BELIEVE IN THE ABILITY.
AND SOMETIMES UP. WE LOOK AT IT
ONE WAY BUT THEN. YOU KNOW YOU
HAVE TO LOOK AT IT AND REALITY
IN. TERMS OF WHAT WE REALLY
GOING. TO HELP YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WHO'VE BEEN GONE ASTRAY.
BASICALLY REBUILD THEIR LIVES
IS GOING TO TAKE SOME WORK. AND
SOMETIMES IT TAKES OF SUCCESS
AND FAILURE STORY ASKING TAT.
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. BUT PEOPLE
STILL GET UP. AND STILL REPEAL
THE LICENSE I THINK THAT'S
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. I THINK IT
IS REALLY- YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS I THINK THAT WE HAVE
CONSTANTLY SAID WHAT. BOTH OF
THE CYCLE BECAUSE WITH YOU LOOK
AT. WHAT HAS HAPPENED WITH US
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT AND OVER.
NUMBER PRISONS AND ALL KINDS OF
THINGS. WE KEEP SAYING WE NEED
A BETTER WAY TO ASSESS PEOPLE.
BASICALLY MAKE SURE THAT WHEN
WE GIVE. A HARD. TIME THE BILL
WILL BE THE ONES WHO NEED A
HARD TIME VERSUS. A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO COME IN WE GIVE HIM A
HARD TIME. AND WE MAKE THEIR
LIVES WORSE BECAUSE PRISON IS
HARD. SO TALKING ABOUT
DIVERSION ROGRAMS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION HALF. IS
IMPORTANT OPTIONS THAT PEOPLE
HAVE BECAUSE KEEP IN MIND IS
NOT EASY. TO GET TO THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM. IT IS NOT
EASY TO GET OUT OF A DIVERSION
PROGRAM. BECAUSE ONCE YOU GET
IN IT YOU ARE CONSTANTLY
MONITORED AND SUPPORTED. AND
HAS SOLD IF YOU FALL OFF ONE
LITTLE BIT YOU'RE OUT. YOU'RE
OUT OF THE DIVERSION PROGRAM
AND THEN YOU'RE BACK INTO THE
REGION WHICH- WHICH OF THE
FELONY OR WHATEVER IT WAS. SO
IT'S NOT AN EASY THING WHEN YOU
TALK TO JUDGES AND- OTHERS THAT
IT'S NOT AN EASY THING TO DO.
AND GIVING JUDGES SOME
DISCRETION GIVING IDA SOME
DISCRETION TO REALLY MAKE.
DECISIONS BASED ON. WHO WE SEE.
BEFORE THEM AND WHAT THAT
PERSON'S POTENTIAL IS WHAT.
PASSES BEEN. BECOME IMPORTANT
ACT I KNOW WHEN WE WERE. DOING
THINGS. FOR YEARS AGO WHEN WE-
AT. OUT OF THINGS THAT WE- IT
WOULD TAKE THE BAIT ALL RIGHT.
VERSION PROGRAMS THAT INVOLVES
AND SOCIAL WORK IN ALL KINDS OF
FOLKS MAKE THESE TO. AND IF
QUITE INTENSIVE AND EVERYONE
DID MAKE IT THROUGH THE
DIVERSION PROGRAM YOU KNOW THEY
DIDN'T MAKE IT BUT THOSE WHO
DID BOB YOU KNOW DID SOMETHING
MUCH MORE IMPORTANT TERMS OF
BUILDING THEIR LIVES AND GO
BACK AND HAVING ONLY HNGING
OVER HERE. COMING OUT. BUT I
ALSO THINK SO THE THINGS ARE
COMP. AND NONE OF THEM ARE.
GUARANTEE YOU KNOW OUR PRISON
SYSTEM IS A CRAP SHOOT YOU KNOW
WHETHER THAT AND THEY REALLY
REAL BILL THE TABLE TO MAKE
THEM WORK AND SO IT'S A
CONSTANT EFFORT TO. TO DEAL
WITH THE CHALLENGES OF JUST
PEOPLE WHO FLIES IN HOW IN THE
AND WHAT HUMAN BEINGS DO- AND
SO IT'S NONE OF IT IS SECURED
AND ABSOLUTE AND WE FOUND THAT
MANY OF OUR ABSOLUTE PROGRAM TO
ONES THAT DON'T WORK WHEN WE
HAVE AN ABSOLUTE AMOUNT OF
SENSE. THAT A PERSON HAS TO
HAVE BEEN ABLE DETERMINES. IT
AND WE SEE IT THREE STRIKES
OKAY THREE STRIKES AMEND WHAT
THE STRATEGY IS YOU GET IT'S
NOT A PEOPLE AND YOU GET X.
NUMBER OF YEARS AND SO WE GET
SOMEOF THESE FOLKS. IN PRISON
FOR. THIRTY FOUR. UNDER THIS
TERM IS BLOWING UP. AND ALL OF
OUR- BECAUSE A THE- OF THE LACK
OF SINCE IT'S- WE HAVE. IN THE
IN THE IN THE BIG. OF A FIVE.
SO YOU KNOW WE'VE BEEN TRYING
TO BACK OUT OF THAT ABSOLUTE
STUFF. AND GET TO THE POINT
WHERE OUR JUDGES AND OUR- AND
LAWYERS AND OTHERS HAVE SOME
DISCRETION TO MAKE- RATHER THAN
JUST BELIEVING THAT YOU HAVE TO
GET X. NUMBER OF YEARS YOU HAVE
TO HAVE THIS AND HAVE TO HAVE
THAT- THAT. BEEN DOING- TIME
FRAME I WOULD GO TO COURT WITH
PEOPLE WHO WOULD ALMOST BE IS
IF. THE ONLY THING YOU HAVE TO
SHOW UP AND IT WILL GIVE THEM
HAVE CALCULATED NEVER. AND
THEY- HAD A SYSTEM IN SO MANY
YEARS YOU HAVE SO MANY SO. MANY
FIND THESE ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
YEARS. BASED ON US TRYING TO
BE. HARD ON CRIME HARD ON
INDIVIDUALS. MAKER EVEN SO WITH
THIS ONE. AND WE DON'T SEE ANY
FEEL. SAFER THAN WE HAD BEFORE
SO. AS WE LOOK AT IS- I WAS
SAFE TRY TO LOOK AT THIS
DISCRETION HAVE. SOMEBODY
SOMETHING. I JUDGES. OF THE
BILL SHOW ME TO JUDGE. AND.
MAKE SOME. YOUR BILL TO. EVERY
NOW THEN LOOK A PERSON SEE THEM
LIVE. THAN SOME ELSE ALL. AND
THEY PUT SOME OF RESTRAINTS AND
SOME. SOME FOCUS ON SO I THINK.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE. CONTINUE TO
LOOK AT THAT AND WE CAN THINK
OF THE MOST EXTREME CASES. AND
WE ALWAYS LOOK AT THOSE WITH
THE ALSO SOME CASES THAT ARE
NOT THAT EXTREME. THEY NEED
SOME DISCRETION WITH THAT. I
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR- FOR
STAFFER FINALLY. OF GETTING TO
THE POINT WHO WHO WAS SAYING WE
REALLY GOING TO CLOSE TO
PRISONS. AND THIS IS THE DATE
THAT WE'RE GOING TO DO WHAT
WE'VE BEEN STRUGGLING WITH THIS
FOR YEARS. AND I'M OPTIMISTIC
FROM SOME OF THE THINGS I'VE
SEEN THAT THERE WILL BE SOME
STANDARDS. BY WHICH WE JUDGE
THOSE THOSE PLACES THAT WOULD
BE CLOSE. BECAUSE WE DIDN'T
WANT TO FIND OURSELVES- IN A
POSITION WHERE WE DIDN'T HAVE
STANDARDS AND THEN. WE'RE
CLOSING YOUR PRISON BUT THAT
YOUR PRESENT AND NOBODY CAN
TELL YOU WHAT. WAS IT BASED ON.
THE NEED WAS A BASED ON HOW
MUCH. MAINTENANCE NEED TO
HAPPEN WAS IT BASED ON WHAT THE
NOT THE PROGRAMS THAT WERE. IN
IT. WE'RE WE'RE CORRECT ARE WE
REALLY DOING ANY SAVINGS DOES
THIS LEAVE. WITH A SYSTEM.
STILL IS ABLE TO MEET THESE TEN
OR FIFTEEN DIFFERENT NEEDS AND
ME THAT BECOME IMPORTANT.
YOU'VE PROBABLY SEEN OKAY. WITH
GRAPPLING WITH OBVIOUSLY OF THE
VIRUS IN PRISON STILL GONNA
HAVE SOME HEARINGS ON THAT.
THOSE WHO INTERESTED BECAUSE-
WE HAVE BEEN DEMAND. CAN ASK.
HI CAN. AND THE HAVE NOTS. HAD
A PLAN THAT WAS A- PLAN. AND
ALL WE SEEM HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
QUOTE ANOTHER PLACE IN TERMS
PLAN WHICH- OUR OUR OF. THE
PERSON WHO'S IN CHARGE OF THE
PRISON AND NOW A GUY WHO HAS
THE OVERSIGHT AS WELL AS OUR-
INSPECTOR GENERAL AS WELL AS
OUR WAR. AS WELL AS I HEALTH
DEPARTMENT IN THOSE THINGS AND
NOT. FUNCTIONING WELL. TOGETHER
AND AT THE RESULT SEE WHAT WE
GET. AND SO WE'VE BEEN.
CONCERNED ABOUT AND SOME OF YOU
HAVE. ISSUES WITH THE BUT WE'VE
BEEN CONCERNED AND I'M WE- I
DON'T. IS THE ALSO I'M NOT.
THAT THEY WILL FALL THAT
PROBLEM. WE HAD A CONVERSATION
YOU. WITH AND HAVE COME. IN
HEARING. BUT I'D SEE OF. IN MY
MIND THAT I DON'T SEE THAT THE
PAST FOR WHAT WOULD BE BETTER
OFF WITHOUT SOME DRAMATIC
CHANGES. IN WHO'S RUNNING FOR
AT THIS POINT. THAT'S NOT A
STATEMENT BUT I DON'T THINK
STAFF ARE WORKING HARD ON THOSE
ISSUES. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. SAY NO OTHER COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT. ARE THERE IN FORTY TWO
A TWO OR A STACK STATE. ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY SAYING
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO TO AB
NINETY. THE SERVICE FROM AT THE-
AB NINETY IS THAT
TRANSPORTATION TRAILER BILL ALL
MENTIONED TWO ITEMS OF NOTE
WITH THAT NEVER FIRST IS
STATUTORY RELIEF AT FOR LOCAL
TRANSIT AGENCIES- FOR EXAMPLE-
SOME OF THESE REQUIREMENTS FOR
WAY TOO AT THE CHARGING A FAIR
ISN'T FAIR REVENUES OR
RIDERSHIP REQUIREMENTS AND THIS
BILL BASICALLY MAKE SOME
CHANGES TO ACCOUNT FOR THE
DISRUPTIONS CAUSED BY CODED. IN
TERMS OF THE INTERACTION OF
THOSE ENTITIES WITH STATE LAW
AND STATE PROGRAMS AND THE
SECOND IS RELATED TO HIGH SPEED
RAIL- THIS TRAILER BILL WOULD
DELAY THE RELEASE OF THE
BUSINESS PLAN UNTIL DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH OF THIS YEAR- AND
BECAUSE THAT IS LATER IN THE
YEAR AT THE PROJECT UPDATE
REPORT NEXT SPRING I WOULD NOT
BE TAKING PLACE- SO DELAYS THE
DEADLINE FOR THE BUSINESS PLAN.
THANK YOU MISS FROM. THE US SO
ON THAT NOTE SO YOUR
JUSTIFICATION FOR ELIMINATING A
PROJECT UPDATE FROM THE
CALIFORNIA HAS A REAL PRO OF
PROGRAM IS THAT. IT WAS YOU'RE
GONNA PUSH BACK THE TWENTY
TWENTY SO WE DON'T NEED ONE
TWENTY ONE. SO LET ME TURN IT
OVER MARK AND ROSE ON THE LINE
AND HE CAN TALK ABOUT THE
INTERACTION BETWEEN THOSE TWO
ITEMS. THE FINANCE AND SO THAT
THE LANGUAGE HERE IS THE
CORRELATIVE TO THE HIGH THE
BILL BUSINESS PLAN THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY DUE OUT OF IT YOU
EVERY TWO YEAR AND HIGH SPEED
RAIL DID CRITICS ONE NEXT YEAR-
IT- CAME OUT THE FLAT THE
WORKER SUCH BORING- THAT WE
DON'T SIXTY DAYS. NOTES BUT YOU
PASSED BY NAY- BUT- OBVIOUSLY A
LOT HAPPENED FROM THE BETWEEN
THE TIME THAT FOR NOW AND FIND
OUT- AND THAT DEADLINE AND SO
THIS THISDELAY LANGUAGES
ACTUALLY AT THE REQUEST OF THE
ASSEMBLY- TO GIVE ME A FORTY
MORE TIME- WE HAVE TO CONSIDER
EVERYTHING THAT AND THE PLAN-
ESPECIALLY AS THEY RELATE. TO
THE CALL THE CRISIS. AND SO IT
SHOULD COME OUT IN DECEMBER AND
THEN- ON THE IDEA TO VEGAS WHEN
THE FUNDING PLAN THE BILL WOULD
STILL. HAVE THAT NEXT YEAR I
PLAYED. THIS SITE OUT TIME HERE
BUT I SUCH THAT JUST MAKE SURE.
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE IS THERE
A BUSINESS PLAN OR A REPORT
THAT'S GOING TO BE COMING TO
THE LEGISLATURE. FROM HIGH
SPEED RAIL. SO THANK YOU IN
TWENTY TWENTY AT THAT THE PLAN
IS TO IT WILL COME OUT BUT IT
WILL BE AT THE DECEMBER AND
THEN IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE- A
FUNDING PLAN. WELCOME OUT. A
FUNDING PLAN WILL COME OUT. A
WINNER WOULD THAT BE. BECAUSE
IT IS YOUR ELIMINATING THE
REQUEST HERE YOU SO THE HIGH TO
OTHERS AND GIVE US A FUNDING
PLAN BUT NOT A PROJECT UPDATE.
NO SIR THE- EVER LOW THE WAIT
SET UP IS THAT WE HAVE A
BUSINESS PLAN THE- AFTER
CORRELATES WITH FORTY HAVE TO
PUT OUT OF THE YEAR. SO THE
LANGUAGE HERE DISTILLATE THAT
BUSINESS PLAN AND THEN NEXT
YEAR THERE WOULD BE A FUNDING
PLAN ASSOCIATED WITH THAT. OKAY
SO WE ARE GETTING SOMETHING
NEXT YEAR. YEAH OKAY SO I GUESS
THEN WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF
ELIMINATING THEIR THEIR PROJECT
UPDATE REPORT WHY WHAT WHY
CAN'T WE GET TO REPORTS I MEAN
LOOK THERE'S SO MUCH GOING ON
WITH HIGH SPEED RAIL THINGS ARE
CHANGING MONTH BY MONTH THEY'RE
THEY'RE EXPANDING ITS NAME
AGAIN NOT OF DOLLARS- THE
FEDERAL MONEY THAT THERE'S A
FEDERAL DEADLINE AND TWENTY
TWENTY. AND YEAH THEY COULD BE
CALLED BACK I THINK THAT WOULD
I WOULD MAKE THE ARGUMENT THAT
WE THOUGHT WE NEED MORE OF MORE
UPDATE ON- A ON A REGULAR BASIS
HIGH SPEED RAIL BECAUSE OF ALL
THE THINGS ALL THOSE TAPPING
NOT LESS. OKAY WELL. ONE OF THE
THINGS. NOTE THOUGH IT- BUT THE
REAL OF FORTY QUOTE. THERE THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU'RE ASKING
ABOUT THE UPDATED EXPENDITURE
RECORDS- ON WINE ON THE
WEBSITE. THEY PUT THEM ON A
MONTHLY BASIS- BUT THERE'S-
NOT. A LOT OF INFORMATION
THAT'S AVAILABLE. BUT CERTAINLY
IF ANYBODY IS INTERESTED AND
GOING THROUGH AND SEEN. AND
UNDERSTAND BETTER EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT. I THAT
INFORMATION IS ALL. AVAILABLE
ON THE AFFORD WEBSITE. AND SO
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE AT THE
PLANNER FOR PLAN THE OBJECT
THEY PROVIDE THEM UPDATE AND
THE PROJECT UPDATE REPORTS.
KIND OF PULL TOGETHER SOME OF
THAT INFORMATION BUT CERTAINLY
ALL AVAILABLE THERE. HELLO YOU
LOOK AT SOME OF THE THAT THE
BUSINESS PLAN TWENTY PLAN WITH
THIS PLAN THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT HERE- THAT A LOT OF THAT
IS LOOKING FORWARD AND SAYING
OKAY WELL. BASED ON WHERE WE'RE
AT. HERE IS. THAT WE SEE THAT
PROJECT AT THE END IN THE
COMING YEARS. SO THE WAY YOU
DESCRIBED IT- THE OUTLOOK
LOOKING FORWARD THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT REPORT IS IN IT. YES
THEY COULD USE IT EVERY COUPLE
OF YEARS BUT IF. YOU'RE
ELIMINATING THAT REPORT FOR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I'M SORRY SO.
YEP WHAT IS THE NEXT BILL HERE
WOULD JUST THE WAY IT DOES NOT
PLAN THAT IS SCHEDULED TO COME
OUT WHAT COULD NOT COME UP WITH
THAT NAY AND NOW MOVES. NUMBER
RIGHT I LOOK I UNDERSTAND THAT
YOU'RE DELAYING THE DECEMBER
FIFTH YOU'RE DELAYING THE- MAY
FIRST TO TWENTY DECEMBER
FIFTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY BUT-
YOU ALSO ARE ELIMINATE THE
REQUIREMENT THAT IF THERE WOULD
BE PROVIDED PROJECT UP A REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE. UP ON OR
BEFORE MARCH FIRST. TWENTY ONE.
AND THAT IS. IN THAT
INFORMATION WILL BE. PROVIDED
AS PART OF THE THAT DID NOT
PLAN TO SOME EXTENT AND THEN
CERTAINLY THAT INFORMATION IS
STILL AVAILABLE ON THE FORTY
FOOT THAT CAR. OKAY I'M NOT
GONNA HAVE GO BACK AND FORTH ON
THE ON DATES I'M JUST SAYING
THAT IT SEEMS A LITTLE TONE
DEAF THAT AT A TIME WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE WANTS MORE
INFORMATION FROM THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL AUTHORITY THAT YOU'RE
ACTUALLY GIVING US LESS. SO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
COMMENTS. SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS PUBLIC COMMENT. IN
THAT PEOPLE IN FACT STATE OR
THEIR PLEASE LINE UP TO GO HAD.
IS IT ON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTMAS KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF
THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE SUPPORT THE
TRANSIT OPERATION PROVISIONS OF
THIS BILL AND THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE FOR
THEM. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
PUBLIC COMMENT. REPUBLICAN IN A
SACK STATE. THE FIRST SINGLE
FURTHER PUBLIC COMMENT LET'S GO
TO IT AB NINETY TWO. YES AB
NINETY TWO IS THATTHE
RESOURCES TRAILER BILL- I'LL
JUST MENTION TO PROVISIONS
FIRST ARE ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AND CLARIFICATIONS
REGARDING THE LEAD ACID BATTERY
CLEANUP FUND AND THAT SECOND
AND WE KNOW THERE'S BEEN
DISCUSSION OF THIS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING FOUR OH
ONE CERTIFICATION ALLOWING
EARLIER CERTIFICATION FOR THE
STATE WATER RESOURCES CONTROL
BOARD UNDER CERTAIN SPECIFIED
CIRCUMSTANCES. ABOUT HAVING TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
ANY QUESTIONS. SINGLE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE. CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER KELLY ON
BEHALF OF THE HUMBLE AND
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES AND
WE SUPPORT THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AUTHORITY PROVISIONS OF THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT. THE CARD
IS GOING TO KEEP MOVING GOING
TO AB NINETY THREE. EIGHTEEN
NINETY THREE RELATES TO THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT- DE IT
BUDGET AGREEMENT THAT IS BEFORE
YOU FOR SERVICE THE EXPANDED
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AS
WELL AS THAT WITHIN AT THE
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT THAT WAS
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE LAST
YEAR. IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
AGREEMENT BEFORE YOU ALSO
EXPANDS ELIGIBILITY FOR THE
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT AND
RELATED YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDITS
FOR UNDOCUMENTED FILERS FILING
TAX RETURNS IN CALIFORNIA. AS
LONG AS THEY HAVE A LEAST ONE
CHILD UNDER THE AGE OF SIX.
THANK YOU QUESTIONS MR WROTE.
MR VISHWANATHAN A WHAT'S THE
COST OF EXPANDING THE EITC TO
THE THAT UNDOCUMENTED
POPULATION. SO IN THIS FIRST
YEAR WE ARE PROJECTING ACOSTA
SIXTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. SO
OUT OF CURIOSITY WHAT'S THE
RATIONALE IN PICKING THIS YEAR
TO DO THAT EXPANSION BECAUSE I
MEAN OBVIOUSLY WORK WITH AN
AGONIZING THE LAST COUPLE OF
MONTHS OVER- THAT THEIR PAINFUL
CUTS THE REVENUE MATRIX TO
PROGRAMS ACROSS THE STATE AND
YET HERE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
SPENDING OVER SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON EXPANSION OF THIS
CONTROVERSIAL PROGRAM. YES I'LL
MAKE TO ITS I THINK THE FIRST
IS THAT- YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT YOU KNOW WE'VE YOU KNOW
LOOK AT THE WHOLE BUDGET YOU
CERTAINLY SOMETHING NAY
REVISION- VERY CLEAR EYED ABOUT
THE FISCAL CHALLENGES WE FACE.
AT THE SAME TIME ONE OF THE
PRIORITIES FOR THE GOVERNOR AND
THE ADMINISTRATION WAS WHEN I
CAME TO CORP SAFETY NET.
PROGRAMS THAT AFFECT LOW INCOME
FAMILIES OR FAMILIES THAT ARE
LIVING IN POVERTY OR CLOSE TO
THE POVERTY LINE AND OFTEN
WORKING FAMILIES WE'RE GONNA
TRY TO PRESERVE. SOME OF THOSE
BENEFITS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE SO
YOU SEE THIS IN THE FACT THAT
THERE ARE. NO CHANGES TO
MEDICARE ELIGIBILITY NO CHANGES
TO CAL WORKS ELIGIBILITY FOR
CALPERS GRANTS OR THE SIZE OF
THOSE GRANTS. NO CHANGES TO AT
THE SIGN THAT SAYS- AND THAT
WOULD BE THE REASON WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION PRIORITIZED.
PRESERVING THE EARNED INCOME
TAX CREDIT AND THEN WHEN IT
COMES TO EXPAND STAND- IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD CAN I WE KNOW THAT.
I ALREADY SEVERAL LET NIGHT OF
LEADERS AND THE MINUTE. TO NOT
HAVE TO. WITH LANGUAGE. I THINK
I MADE THE POINT ITS THE-
EXPANDING THIS PROGRAM AT
SUBSTANTIAL COST IS DIFFICULT
TO JUSTIFY A YEAR WHEN WE HAVE
SUCH A LARGE DEFICIT IN OUR
HAVING TO CUT OTHER PROGRAMS
THAT I THINK ALSO HAVE
CHAMPIONS IN THE LEGISLATURE.
THEY ARE DIRECTLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- FIRST I
WANTED TO RECOGNIZE YOUR
ADVOCACY MISTER CHAIR IN THE
SPACE FOR A LONG TIME FOR THE
I. T. C. AND ONE OF OUR
KNOWLEDGE AND APPRECIATE THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR MAKING THIS
EXPANSION I WANT TO START BY
SAYING THAT OUR TAXPAYERS
PEOPLE WHO ARE WORKING AND-
STRUGGLING TO PUT FOOD ON THEIR
TABLE AND THIS PANDEMIC. SHOWS
US THE ECONOMIC DISTRESS THAT
ARE UNDOCUMENTED FAMILIES ARE
GOING THROUGH REALLY WANT TO
APPRECIATE IF I CAN THE
INVESTMENT IN THIS AREA SAYS IT
WILL HELP MANY PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY TO MAKE ENDS MEET
SPECIFICALLY THOSE WHO HELP
YOUNG FAMILIES I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THEY SPEAK
ABOUT THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN OUTREACH THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT IN FOR
BOTH CULTURAL AND LINGUISTIC.
OPPORTUNITIES FOR US TO MAKE
SURE OUR COMMUNITIES ARE ABLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THESE
PROGRAMS AS I THINK HE
INSTRUMENTALISTS. WITH THAT I
JUST WANTED. SHE ATTENDED. SO
WITH HAVE A LONG WAY TO GO TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL WORKERS ARE
TREATED EQUALLY HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT THIS IS
A POSITIVE STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION. THANK YOU I ALSO
WANTED JUST TO ADD MY COMMENTS
TO THAT I THINK IT'S- IT THIS
IS A VERY CRITICAL PROGRAM AND
WALL. I KNOW THAT THAT. IT IS
DIFFICULT TO BE ADDING TO A
PARTICULAR PROGRAM. THIS IS A
POPULATION THAT AS WE ALL KNOW
DOES NOT QUALIFY FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE. SO IF
THEY ARE FACING HARDSHIP. S. DE
THE NET THAT OTHER MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS. HOW TO BUILD
THEMSELVES TO SO WHILE WE ARE.
PRUNING AND CUTTING DIFFERENT
AREAS OF THE BUDGET. WE HAVE
GREATLY EXPANDED THE AMOUNT OF
UNEMPLOYMENT. INSURANCE
BENEFITS TO PEOPLE TO MILLIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE THEY'RE
OUT OF WORK IN SO THIS PROGRAM-
WILL HELP THOSE FAMILIES WHO
WERE WORKING THAT IN PARTICULAR
HARD WORKING- AND ARE
STRUGGLING AND I THINK THIS IS
ONE OF THE- WAYS THAT WE COULD
TO THEM WITH. PROGRAM I THINK
MAKES A SICK CAN AMOUNT OF
SENSE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WE
HAD CHAMPION LEGISLATIVELY LAST
YEAR I BROUGHT  BROADER
PROGRAM WE'RE UNABLE TO GET IT.
BUT THE FACT THAT THESE
FAMILIES THESE WORKING FAMILIES
AS MY COLLEAGUE FROM FRESNO
SENATE ARE UNABLE TO ACCESS
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- WHEN
THEY WERE WORKING BUT THEY
CAN'T BECAUSE- OF THEIR-
DOCUMENTATION STATUS I THINK.
THIS PROGRAM MAKES A LOT OF
SENSE IT'S A VERY SMALL
INVESTMENT CONSIDERING
DIFFERENT TO THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE'VE SPENT ON
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE- TO
REALLY HELP A FEW THESE
FAMILIES WHO ARE ARE VERY MUCH
STRUGGLING SO. I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR WORKING ON
THAT WITH US AS WELL. SINGLE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS ONE OF
THE PUBLIC COMMENT ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT ON THIS ISSUE. AB
NINETY THREE. NOT SEEING ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT LET'S GO TO AB
ONE HUNDRED. AB ONE HUNDRED IS
ANOTHER AT STATE GOVERNMENT
DALE AND ALL THAT YOU TO
PROVISIONS OF DOUBT- THE FIRST
IS REGARDING- ELECTION
ADMINISTRATION FUNDS AND SO
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW
PREVIOUSLY- ALLOCATED FUNDS TO
BE USED FOR THE NOVEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTIONS- AND THEN THE
SECOND ITEM OF NOTE AND THIS.
IS THE TRANSFER OF THE SEISMIC
SAFETY MISSION TO THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND WE DO BELIEVE THAT
THIS WILL PROVIDE GREATER ON
WINE RED IN THE FACE OF THAT
TYPE OF DISASTER. QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS ON. AB ONE HUNDRED.
CASEY NOTHING FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANY PUBLIC ON. A
PUBLIC COMMENT ON AB ONE
HUNDRED. OKAY WHAT'S GOOD AB
ONE OF TWO. AB ONE OR TWO
REFERS TO THE CAL SAVERS
PROGRAM- FORMERLY KNOWN A
COUPLE YEARS AGO I SECURE
CHOICE AND THIS BILL MAKES OF
TECHNICAL CHANGES RELATED TO
THE ENFORCEMENT OF
RESPONSIBILITIES AND TRANSFERS
THOSE FROM THE EMPLOYMENT
DEVELOPMENT DEPARTMENT TO THE
CAL SAVERS BOARD AS WELL AS
WORKING WITH THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. AND IT ALSO CLARIFIES
THE OPT IN OPT OUT REQUIREMENTS
FOR THIS PROGRAM UNDER CERTAIN
CIRCUMSTANCES. THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS. THIS AROUND. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR A CAN YOU TELL
US WHAT THE RATIONALE WAS FOR
SHIFTING RESPONSIBILITY FOR
ENFORCEMENT FROM THE EDT TO THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD BECAUSE EDT
STILL SEEMS LIKE A NATURAL FIT
GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE IT'S
EMPLOYERS THAT ARE IMPLEMENTING
THE PROGRAM. YES I'VE GOT
EVELYN SEE SOME THE WIND YOU
KNOW WE LOOKED AT THIS- YOU
KNOW AND HEARD FROM THAT
STAKEHOLDERS AND CAL AND THE
CAL SAVERS ARE PROGRAMMED AND
THEY BELIEVE THAT THIS MADE THE
MOST SENSE FOR THE EFFECTIVE
ADMINISTRATION FOR THE PROGRAM
BACK. LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
EVELYN STAYS ON THE PHONE. YES
THIS IS EVELYN. DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND AS- IT'S OUR BEST A
LOT THEN- I BELIEVE- EXPRESSED-
DE SB OUT JUSTIFICATION FOR
THAT'S CORRECTLY- SO ACCORDING
TO CAL SAVERS I DO TO THE CALL
THE NINETEEN- PANDEMIC EIGHTIES
EXPERIENCING SEVERE RESOURCE
CONSTRAINTS AS IT CONTENDS WITH
LABOR MARKET DISRUPTIONS IN
RECORD BREAKING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE CLAIMS. THAT CONTINUE
TO INCREASE AND THEREFORE AND
EIGHTY HE HAD INDICATED THEY
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO PERFORM
THE DUTY IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
CHURCH SO I UNDERSTAND THAT BUT
WE'RE MAKING A STRUCTURAL
DECISION THAT'S GOING TO LAST
FOR MANY YEARS THIS IS. A
TEMPORARY PROBLEM WITH EDT AND
I KNOW THAT. MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE NEED
FOR- INCREASING STAFFING EDH
TRYING US ALL THIS WORKLOAD
ISSUE FOR THEM BUT I MEAN
HOPEFULLY THAT'S NOT GOING TO
BE THE CASE SEVERAL YEARS FROM
NOW ON WE'RE STILL GOING TO BE
HAVING TO ADMINISTER THIS
PROGRAM I WAS JUST. CONCERNED
THAT WERE BEING TOO HASTY HERE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK
YOU ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON
AB ONE OF. TO AB ONE TO ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY LET'S GO
TO AB ONE OH THREE. AB ONE OF
THREE REFERS AT TO UNEMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION- AND  WILL GO TO
CHANGES AT THE FIRST IS WITH
REGARDING- COVERT SPECIFIC
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
PROGRAMS- THIS BILL SAYS THAT
THESE PAYMENTS SHOULD NOT BE
CHARGED AGAINST THE EMPLOYERS
PRESERVE ACCOUNT- AND THIS
BEING TOLD JULY OF NEXT YEAR OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- AND THEN THE
SECOND ITEM OF NOTE. OF RELATES
TO TRIGGERS ON CERTAIN BENEFITS
THAT ARE RELATED TO THE FAT AT
CORONA VIRUS RESPONSE I. GOT
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT-
AND SO- HAPPY TO TAKE ANY
QUESTIONS AND I'VE GOT DIRECTLY
ON HER TEAM ON THE LINE AS WELL
WITH REGARD TO YOU I ISSUES. MR
WOULD. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
OF FIRST LET ME SAY THAT I AM
VERY HAPPY TO SEE THAT WE ARE
PAYING SOME ATTENTION TO
SOMETHING THAT I THINK IT IS IN
DIRE NEED OF ADDRESSING- THE
EDT IS GOING TO RECALCULATE THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CONTRIBUTION RATES FOR EVERY
EMPLOYER IN THE STATE AND
DECEMBER AND IF WE DON'T TAKE
ACTION THEN EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
THESE LAYOFFS THAT OCCURRED. AT
NO FAULT OF THE BUSINESS BUT AT
YOU KNOW AT AT THE REQUEST OF
THE GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO GET
NOW AND UP ANY CHARGE AGAINST
THESE EMPLOYERS AT THE ACTUALLY
ON TIME IT'S GOING TO BE
THEY'RE TRYING EMERGE FROM THIS
CRISIS AND- THEY'RE GONNA BE
STRUGGLING SO BOB THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PAYING ATTENTION
TO THAT I KNOW A LOT OF UPSET
AND- THE PUSH. THIS THE PART OF
THE BILL THAT TALKS ABOUT THE
EXPANSION OF UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY I FOUND A
LITTLE PUZZLING- I'M HAVING
DIFFICULTY FOLLOWING EXACTLY
HOW MUCH THAT EXPERT THAT-
ELIGIBILITY IS BEING EXPANDED
AND WHO IS PAYING FOR IT SO
COULD YOU DETAIL THAT FORUM FOR
US PLEASE. YES TURN IT OVER TO
ERICA AND HER TEAM AND THEY CAN
TALK ABOUT THAT IN DETAIL.
GETTING OUT BRAND WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SO THE
TRAILER BILL AN ACTUAL BENEFIT
WEEK THE TRAILER BILL WOULD ADD
AN ADDITIONAL SEVEN WEEKS
HOWEVER WHAT WOULD ENACTING
NEED LONG CHARGING PROVISIONS
WHAT HAPPENED IS THAT. THE
ENTIRE TWENTY WEEKS OF THE
EXTENDED PROGRAM WOULD BE
FEDERALLY FUNDED WITHOUT THESE
CHANGES TO THE NON CHARGING
PERVADES AND THE STATE WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR PAYING 50% OF
THE COST FOR THE FIRST THIRTEEN
WEEKS. AGAIN UNDER THIS TRAILER
BILL WITH THE NON CHARGING
PROVISIONS. IT'S AN ADDITIONAL
SEVEN WEEKS THAT SAID. HE WE
COULD BE EARLY FUND AT. OKAY SO
I WANNA MAKE SURE I UNDER
BECAUSE I FOUND THIS OF THE
BILL LANGUAGE A LITTLE
CONFUSING- IF WE MAKE THIS
CHANGE. THE PAYMENT FOR THOSE
EXTRA WEEKS OF- UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE ELIGIBILITY WILL BE
1100% REIMBURSED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. IF WE ENACTED NON
CHARGING PROVISIONS CORRECT. SO
THE TITLE TWELVE LOANS THAT
WE'VE BEEN FORCED TO TAKE TO
SHORE UP THE SOLVENCY OF OUR
UNEMPLOYMENT SYSTEM ARE NOT
GOING TO BE AFFECTED BY
EXPANDING THAT ELIGIBILITY IS
THAT RIGHT. THAT IS CORRECT
OKAY WELL THANK YOU I- ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION- ALTHOUGH I
THINK IT'S- IT'S LAUDABLE THAT
WE'RE TAKING ACTION ON MAKING
SURE THAT LAYOFFS ARE NOT
COUNTING EPIDEMIC RELATED
LAYOFFS DON'T COUNT AGAINST
EMPLOYERS- CONTRIBUTION RATES
ARE WE DOING ANYTHING ABOUT THE
EMERGENCY SOLVENCY SURCHARGE
BECAUSE- GIVEN ALL THESE CLAIMS
I'M SURE THAT THAT'S GOING TO
BE KICKING AND NEXT YEAR. AND I
DIDN'T SEE ANYTHING THE TRAILER
BILL RELATING TO THAT. WHAT ARE
YOUR QUESTIONS OKAY SO ARE WE
ARE SAYING THAT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO CARRY OUT. EPIDEMIC RELATED
LAYOFFS AGAINST EMPLOYERS-
EXPERIENCE RATIO WOULD WE
RECALCULATE THEIR RATES FOR
NEXT YEAR HOWEVER THE STATE
COULD ALSO HAS A PROVISION THAT
SAYS. THAT IF THE UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE FUND BECOMES
INSOLVENT THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
SOLVENCY SURCHARGE THAT'S ADDED
SO I'M I'M MY QUESTION IS A
WHAT GOOD DOES IT DO. TO SAY TO
AN EMPLOYER OKAY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO CHARGE LAYOFFS AGAINST
YOUR EXPERIENCE RATE IF WE THEN
TURN AROUND AND ALSO IMPOSE AN
EMERGENCY SOLVENCY SURCHARGE
THAT ESSENTIALLY DOES THE SAME
THING. THE MORNING AFTER
OBERNOLTE THIS IS ERIC CALLING
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
AND JUST TO CLARIFY ARE YOU
THINKING- OF THE FEDERAL
UNEMPLOYMENT CáC. THE TO THE
THAT WOULD KICK IN- THE
REDUCTION IN THE CREDIT. NO I'M
TALKING ABOUT. WELL LET ME LOOK
IT UP. THIS SECTION NINE
SEVENTY SEVEN OF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE CODE
THAT DICTATES HOW THE
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
CONTRIBUTION RATES ARE
CALCULATED- SAYS THAT IF THE
UNEMPLOYMENT FUND BECOMES
INSOLVENT THERE'S AN EMERGENCY
SOLVENCY SURCHARGE THAT'S
IMPOSED ON EMPLOYERS SO I'M
WONDERING- WHAT GOOD IT DOES TO
NOT CHARGE THESE LAYOFFS
AGAINST THEIR EXPERIENCE RATE.
IF WE THEN TURN AROUND AND
CHARGE THEM EMERGENCY SOLVENCY
SURCHARGE WHEN WE CALCULATE THE
RATES FOR NEXT YEAR MISTER
ARNOLD THE WE MAY HAVE TO WE
HAVE TO VOTE SOON SO WE MADE-
IF YOU. CONSIDER WILL LOOK INTO
THAT RIGHT NOW MAKE SURE WE
HAVE ALL OF OUR FACTS AND WE'LL
GET BACK TO YOU BEFORE THE
AFTERNOON THANK YOU APPRECIATE
THAT THE DOES GOOD WORK ON THE
REST OF IT I I'M REALLY HAPPY
THAT WE'RE ADDRESSING THIS
ISSUE. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
COURTESY OF A COMMON WITH GOOD
A. B. ONE NINETEEN. SO AB ONE
NINETEEN REFERS TO- BARGAINING
UNITS IN EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
AS ALL OF YOU KNOW- BASED ON
THIS BUDGET AGREEMENT THERE ARE
EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION SAVINGS
THAT ARE SCORED IN THIS BILL
AND WHEREVER POSSIBLE AT IT'S
THE GOAL OF THE ADMINISTRATION
AND UNDER THIS BUDGET AGREEMENT
TO ACHIEVE THOSE SAVINGS AT THE
BARGAINING TABLE- SO THIS BILL
MAKES CHANGES ALLOWING FOR THE
RATIFICATION AT AMMO USE IN ANY
ATTACK DEATHS. RELATED TO
SEVERAL BARGAINING UNITS AND
I'LL JUST READ ABOUT BARGAINING
UNITS. 1-346-911-1415 SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN TWENTY AND TWENTY ONE-
ANY PARTICULAR INCLUDES A
PROVISION- BASED ON AT THE
FISCAL YEAR THE NEW FISCAL YEAR
JUST BEING A COUPLE DAYS AWAY-
THAT THESE AGREEMENTS- WOULD BE
RATIFIED- THROUGH THIS BILL
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE. AS
LONG AS IT REFLECTS THE SAVINGS
THAT CONTRIBUTE TO WHAT IS
REFLECTED IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
BUDGET ACT WE KNOW THAT THEIR
NUMBER DIFFERENT PROVISIONS
HERE AND HAPPY TO TAKE
QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER WINTERS. I
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO I
ACTUALLY THINK THE MO USER
LARGELY SUPPORTABLE THAT WERE
PROVING HERE BUT I HAVE SOME-
IMPORTANT CONCERNS WITH ONE
SECTION OF THIS TRAILER BILL.
THE IT SECTION TO GET
APPARENTLY DOES THE
ADMINISTRATION THE AUTHORITY TO
APPROVE ANY ADDITIONAL AMMO USE
THAT THEY NEGOTIATE BETWEEN NOW
AND THE END OF THE MONTH AS
LONG AS THOSE MO USE RESULT IN
SAVINGS TO THE STATE DID I READ
THAT RIGHT BECAUSE- I DID THAT
SEEMS COUNTER INTUITIVE TO ME.
SO THIS IS A VERY TEMPORARY
PROVISION GIVEN THAT THE FACT
THE END OF THE MONTH IT'S JUST
A COUPLE DAYS AWAY AND THAT IF
THESE AGREEMENTS ARE FINALIZED
AFTER THE BEGINNING OF THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR. THERE ARE SEVERAL
CONSEQUENCES RELATED TO THAT
BASED ON WHAT'S IN THE
AGREEMENTS RIGHT NOW BUT LET ME
TURN IT OVER TO MARY HALTER MAN
ON THE PHONE WHO CAN SPEAK TO
THAT QUESTION. MERRY ALTERING
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND YET
FELT GOOD FOR MAKING
UNPRECEDENTED CIRCUMSTANCES.
THERE IS THE PROVISION NOT AS
ALLOWING TO ITS STREAMLINED
RATIFICATION PROCESS FOR ANY
AGREEMENT BETTER REACHED BY
JUNE THIRTIETH. THE NEXT
TUESDAY. I AM ME. AND THAT'S
WILL ENSURE THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
REALIZE THE SAVINGS THAT ARE-
BUDGETING CONTROL SECTION THREE
POINT NINE- AT THE BUDGET BILL
JUNIOR. AND IT WILL ALSO ALLOW
THE TERMS OF THESE AGREEMENTS
TO BE IMPLEMENTED FOR THE JULY
TWENTY TWENTY PAY PERIOD. I
WHICH MAY INCLUDE VARIOUS ITEMS
THAT WOULD HELP MITIGATE THE
IMPACT ON EMPLOYEES BY AND- THE
VARIOUS UNIONS ARE COMING TO
AGREEMENTLAST. AND THEIR
SPECIFIC LIMITATIONS ON WHAT
GREEN CAN BE INCLUDING A
STREAMLINED PROCESS THAT. AND
SO THEY MUST. CONTRIBUTE TO THE
CONTROL SECTION THREE POINT
NINE UPDATING BETTER BUDGET.
AND ANYTHING THAT COMES IN.
AFTER JUNE THIRTIETH THE
STARTING ON JULY ONE NEXT
WEDNESDAY. WE WILL GO BACK TO
THE OLD AND- RATIFICATION A
NOTIFICATION. PROCESS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU
SAY. RATIFICATION PROCESS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
PROCESS WITH NO LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AND I FIND THAT VERY
TROUBLING BECAUSE WE'RE IN
SESSION NOW WE CAME BACK. FOR
THIS HEARING AND FOR A FOUR
SESSION TODAY WE CAN COME BACK
AGAIN IF WE NEED TO RATIFY AMMO
USED BEFORE THE FIRST OF JULY
BUT- TO ME THERE'S- IN MY
THINKING THERE'S NO REASON WHY.
WE SHOULDN'T EXERCISE OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL ROLE IN
APPROVING THESE MO USE SO- I
REALLY AM- REGRETTING THAT
THAT- THAT PROVISION IS IN HERE
BECAUSE OTHERWISE I THINK THIS
BILL WOULD BE PRETTY
UNCONTROVERSIAL. IT THANK YOU
ARE JUST QUESTION TO DEPART
FINANCE WHAT'S THE AS OF THE
WRITING THE BILL WHAT'S THE
OVERALL EMPLOYEE COMPENSATION
SAVINGS IN THE BILL SO THE
OVERALL WHEN IT COMES TO BOTH
GENERAL FUND AND SPECIAL FUNDS
SAVINGS- IT'S A LITTLE UNDER
THREE BILLION DOLLARS SO ABOUT
TWO POINT EIGHT BILLION DOLLARS.
THANK YOU. I SEE NO FURTHER
COMMENT FROM THE COMMITTEE ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT. ON AB ONE
NINETEEN ANY PUBLIC COMMENT.
OKAY GOOD SB NINETY EIGHT. SO
SB NINETY EIGHT IS- THE TRAILER
BILL RELATED TO PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT- WHICH IS FOR K.
TWELVE AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES-
AND BE UPDATED GUARANTEE
ESTIMATE FOR PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT FOR THE COMING YEAR IS
THAT SEVENTY POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS I SHOULD NOTE THAT
THAT'S THAT PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT GENERAL FUND AMOUNT WITH
BUT THE GENERAL FUND AND
PROPERTY TAXES IN ADDITION THIS
BILL ALLOCATE SEVERAL BILLION
DOLLARS IN CORONA VIRUS REALLY
FIND AS WELL AS OTHER FUNDS
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
HELP SUPPORT OUR SCHOOLS IN
THIS TIME OF FISCAL PRESSURE.
AND THIS BILL ALSO INCLUDES A
SUPPLEMENTAL OBLIGATION TO
SCHOOLS BEGINNING THE YEAR
AFTER TWENTY TWENTY DASH TWENTY
TWENTY ONE ON AND IT ALSO
INCLUDES VARIOUS PROVISIONS
RIGHT RIGHT TO ATTENDANCE AND
HOLD HARPER PROVISIONS. DIED ON
ITS WAY THERE'S A. TAKE A
QUESTIONS. MR WANTED TO. THANK
YOU MISTER SO YOU MENTIONED THE
SERVE BILLION DOLLARS IN CORONA
VIRUS RELIEF FUNDING THAT THEY
ARE APPROPRIATE AT THIS BILL
I'M WONDERING WHY THE BILL
SPECIFICALLY EXCLUDES CHARTER
SCHOOLS FROM ELIGIBILITY FOR
THAT FUNDING. I SO LET ME TURN
IT OVER AT JESSICA HOLMES- CAN
SPEAK TO A HOUSE THAT FUNDING
IS ALLOCATED. YES THE WHOLE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION OF TROUBLE
OBERNOLTE- SO IN FACT AND THE-
NOT A WITH ALL CHARTER SCHOOL
FROM AT RISK AT FEDERAL FUNDS
HOWEVER DOES IT. NON THE
CHARTERS THEN THE REASON BEHIND
THAT WAS- THE THUNDER INTENDED
TO ADDRESS COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH- HAVING TO AND CHANGE
GREAT BUT THAT THE WAY THAT
THEY DO BUSINESS IN ORDER TO
MEET- THE- ISSUE FACED WITH
NINETEEN NOT COPY. CHARTER
BECAUSE PROVIDE AT LEAST 80% OF
THEIR INSTRUCTION OUTSIDE OF
THE CLASSROOM- WERE LARGELY AS
NOT AT THAT HEAVILY IMPACTED BY
BECAUSE THE NINETEEN PANDEMIC-
AND SO GIVEN THAT- WE HAVE NOT
INCLUDED THEM AND AS- INTO
THESE FUNDS. I THANK YOU IN
THIS REGARD. YEAH THANK YOU.
OVERALL THIS- EDUCATION- PIECE
OF THE BUDGET. HIS IS A GOOD
BALANCE IT PRETTY MUCH IS VERY
SIMILAR TO WHAT WE HAD PUT
FORWARD A FEW. WEEKS AGO WITH
OUR BUDGET SO GOOD FOR
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS FOR THE MOST
PART IN COVEN NINETEEN. OUR
KIDS AND FRANKLY HELPS US REAL
PUT OUR ECONOMY ESPECIALLY WITH
THE INVESTMENTS IN CHILD CARE.
I THERE ARE THREE OUTSTANDING
ISSUES THAT WE'RE GETTING LOTS
OF QUESTIONS ON FROM. THAT
SCHOOL DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA AND LEGISLATORS. IN
IN- THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
CELLS HOPING THAT FINANCE COULD
HELP MUST ADDRESS THEM TODAY
ONE IS THE DISTANCE LEARNING-
TO IS THIS THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROVISIONS AND EIGHTY A IN
THREE IS LAYOFFS SO MAYBE WE
CAN START. AT THE TOP WITH
DISTANCE LEARNING- I THINK
THERE'S A BIT OF CONFUSION. ON
ON DISTANCE LEARNING SOME
CONFUSION FROM C-SPAN ACTS THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS AS FAR AS- THE
THAT THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
DISTRICTS TO HAVE IN IN IN
SIGHT- SCHOOL BASED LEARNING
VERSES- DISTANCE LEARNING BASED
UPON WHAT ORDERS ARE GIVEN FROM
THEIR LOCAL. HEALTH OFFICIALS
SO CAN YOU HELP ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CONFUSION THERE ON WHAT THE
ACTUAL LAW STATES WHAT THE
REQUIREMENTS ARE. YES JESSICA
HOLMES CAN ACTUALLY SPEAK TO
ALL THREE OF THOSE ISSUES THAT
YOU MENTIONED. THANK YOU YES
REPARTEE SO- ON THE FIRST ISSUE
OF DISTANCE LEARNING WEEKS HAVE
HEARD ON CONFUSION FROM THE
FIELD- REGARDING HOW TO
INTERPRET THAT STATUTE AND WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH YOUR
STAFF AND THE STAFF OF THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO
ENSURE THAT- WE ARE ALL
PROVIDING THE SAME GUIDANCE- IN
OUR CONVERSATIONS WITH- FOLKS
IN THE FIELD BUT- BEYOND THAT
WE ARE ALSO ALL WORKING ON. A
LETTER TO THE JOURNAL TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL CLARITY
AROUND THE INTENT OF THAT
LANGUAGE THE TYPICALLY WHAT WE
ALL DISCUSSED IN WHAT THE
AGREEMENT WAS WITH THAT IN
TERMS OF THE LAND THROUGH WHICH
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- AND AT
CHARTER SCHOOL THE COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION- LOOK
THROUGH IN MAKING DECISIONS
ABOUT THE PROGRAM. EIGHT YOU
SHOULD BE I THINK THAT SHOULD
BE. TO REALLY. THAN MINE FIRST
BEING THE RIGHT OF REASONS THE
PRIORITY SHOULD ALWAYS BE UP OR
IN CLASS. WE KNOW THAT. FOR OUR
POPULATION THAT WHO ARE YOU
KNOW LOW INCOME ENGLISH LEARNER
HIS DISABILITY FOR THE FOR THE
CHILDREN ESPECIALLY IN CRACKING
INSTRUCTION REALLY HAS- THE
BEST- OUTCOMES FOR THEM THE
SECOND THING THAT WE WANT FOLKS
TO KEEP IN MIND WHEN THEY'RE
MAKING DECISIONS ABOUT THE TYPE
PROGRAM THEY'RE GOING TO OFFER
THAT YOU TO DO IT WOULD HELP ME
SAFETY- INFORMAL BUT THEY NEED
TO BE PAYING ATTENTION TO WHAT
IS THE STATE AT ALL GOT. IT
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WHAT IS THEIR LOCAL I'M
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS
GUIDANCE- FOR ENSURING SAFETY
IN THE CLASSROOM BECAUSE OF
COURSE PUBLIC SAFETY IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST FOR ALL OUR
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES ON
THE ALL OF THAT. SOME QUESTION
WHETHER. CAN OFFER A HYPER OR A
DIFFERENT BURNING PRO YOU KNOW
WITHOUT- THE BEACON TO THE
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DOCTOR
CERTAINLY THEY DON'T NEED TO
GET PERMISSION OR APPROVAL IN
ORDER TO DO THAT BUT THEY DO
NEED TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT WHAT
THE REQUIREMENTS ARE HEALTH AND
SAFETY HOW THEY CAN IMPLEMENT
THAT GIVEN- THAT THE
PHILIPPINES AND STAFFAND
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT THEY
CURRENTLY HOT. SO HOPEFULLY
THAT. THIRTY BUT I'M HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY FURTHER YOU MAY HAVE
YEAH I THINK THAT HELPFUL I WAS
GOING TO. SUGGEST THAT EITHER
THAT CLEAN UP LEGISLATION BUT
IF YOU THINK LOWER THE JOURNAL
WOULD SUFFICE THAT THE INTENT
OF THAT. I THINK THAT IS- THAT
THAT SAID- A PATH AS WELL. HE
HE DIDN'T ASK THE ONE OTHER
QUESTION THAT THAT- HAS BEEN
NOW SAYS. WE KNOW THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE ACROSS CALIFORNIA
DIFFERENT OPINIONS ON WHAT TO
DO DURING KOBE NINETEEN- SOME
PARENTS MAY WANT TO KEEP THEIR
KIDS AT HOME. AND SO THERE IS A
RISK ALSO. QUESTIONS AS FAR AS
WHETHER THAT WOULD- PROHIBIT
SCHOOLS FROM OFFERING FOR FROM
OFFERING. OR PROVIDING SOLELY
DISTANCE LEARNING FOR PARENTS
WHO WANT TO KEEP THEIR THEIR
STUDENTS ATHOME DURING THE-
CALL THE NINETEEN ERA. YEAH BUT
THAT THAT'S A REALLY IMPORTANT
QUESTION AND I THINK THAT OUR-
FIRST PRIORITY REALLY IS- TO
ENSURE THAT- EVERY CHILD IS
GIVEN THE OPTION TO THE EXTENT
THAT THAT. HEALTH AND SAFETY
PERMITTED TO HAVE BEEN IN
CLASSROOMS- EXPERIENCE- THAT
THAT CERTAINLY THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY- YOU KNOW I. IT'S
GOING TO BE DIFFICULT TO GUESS
WHAT- CODED NINETEEN IS GOING
TO DO THROUGHOUT THE NEXT YOU
KNOW YEARS THE TO THE EXTENT
THAT YOU KNOW WE HAVE. YOU KNOW%
A WONDERFUL OUTCOME WORKABLE
NINETEEN BECOMES NO LONGER AN
ISSUE FOR US- IT'S CERTAINLY
THE INTENT OF THE STATE WE GO
BACK TO BUSINESS AS USUAL IN
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION- AND THAT
IS. OUR GOAL- FOR SCHOOL TO
THAT ONE OFFER OPTIONS FOR
PARENTS SO FOR EXAMPLE I KNOW
ONE SCHOOL DISTRICT WHO ORDER
TO ALIGN WITH SOCIAL THE
REQUIREMENT THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FACILITIES- TO. TO A COP
PERSONAL BUSINESS AND THEY'RE
OFFERING PARENTS THREE CHOICES
THE FIRST WOULD BE A FULL
CLASSROOM- INSTRUCTIONAL MODEL
THANK YOU HI IN THE WOULD BE.
LEARNING ONLY AND THROUGH THAT
BECAUSE THEY'VE COME OUT READ
TO THEIR PARENTS THEY KNOW THAT
THAT'S GOING TO HELP DOWN LOW.
DOWN THERE ON THAT. TO COMPLY
WITH HEALTHY SAFETY SO I IF THE
QUESTION IS CAN THIS PROVIDE A
DISAPPOINTING ONLY PRO THAT
THEIR PARENTS PREFERENCE IS I
WOULD SAY THAT THAT'S NOT
THAT'S NOT CONTEMPLATE BY THE
LAKE HOWEVER TO THE X. THAT
THAT THERE ARE- PROGRAMS BEING
PUT IN PLACE ON HELP INSURE
HEALTH AND SAFETY AND OPT INTO
THE PROGRAM AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY I THINK. DO THAT
PROVIDES CLARITY THAT YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR OKAY THANK YOU. THE
SECOND ISSUE IS RELATED TO
EIGHTY A AND HOLD HARMLESS AND
SO I UNDERSTAND THAT'S%
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SPECIALLY
AT SCHOOLS HAVE KIDS NOT
SHOWING UP FOR WHATEVER RIGHTY
REASONS AND WE DON'T. WANT TO
HAVE THEM BE- FINANCE AND
STABLE BECAUSE OF THAT SO
CONTINUE WHAT WE DID THIS PAST
SPRING. IN KEEPING SCHOOL
FUNDING- STABLE WITH THAT. AND
OF OUR STANDING IS HOW WE CAME
UP WITH THIS COMPROMISE ON PROP
ANY FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS. IS WE
LOCK IN THE RATE OF LAST YEAR
WITH THE ADDITIONAL- FOR PEOPLE
EIGHTY EIGHT- AMOUNTS- NOT
FOCUSING ON THE ACTUAL HEAD
COUNT. SO THERE'S BEEN- A FEW
SCHOOL DISTRICTS- COUPLE HERE
LOCALLY THAT I'VE ASKED ABOUT
HOW THAT RELATES TO THE TO
GROWING SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
DISTRICTS THAT HAVE- POPULATION
GROWTH SO- WHAT IS OUR ANSWER
TO THEM AS FAR AS HOW THEY BE
ABLE TO SURVIVE. DURING THIS
NEXT- BUDGET YEAR. YES WE'VE
ALSO HEARD THAT QUESTION UNTIL
WHEN WE WERE MAKING THE
DECISION AROUND EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY THE
BUDGET AND DOES NOT INCLUDE ANY
REDUCTION TWO LPS FAST- TO
SPEND FELT THAT THE COLD FOR
WHEN YOU'RE BUT IT KEEPS THE
RATES LARGELY AT NINETEEN
TWENTY LEVEL- AND DOES NOT
INCLUDE SIGNIFICANT REDUCTIONS
TO ANY CATEGORICAL THERE'S LOTS
OF THOSE ARE HUGE. HUGE
MAINTENANCE AS OF FUNDING FOR
SCHOOL- THAT WE THOUGHT WERE
REALLY IMPORTANT WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT SOMETHING LIKE AN
EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS- THERE
ARE COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THAT
WE KNOW THAT IN- IN IN ANY
NORMAL YEAR WE WOULD BE IN A
DECLINING ENROLLMENT
ENVIRONMENT- STATEWIDE. AND
ACOSTA LPS THAT- REFLECT THAT
THAT ONGOING DECLINE HOWEVER
WITHIN EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS
WE ARE AS YOU MENTIONED-
OPENING THE ADA FOR TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH WHAT IT WAS
NINETEEN TWENTY LIKELY TO BE
HIGHER- AND- CREATE THIS. HOT
YOU WERE. WE WERE AT THE WHOLE
HEART THE QUESTION IS REALLY
DOING NOT IMPLEMENT EIGHTY
HARMLESS AND THE THAT HAVE.
WILL BE A TO BE FOR GROW. AND
THOSE THAT HAVE DECLINE WILL
WILL SIMPLY BE FUNDED AT A
LOWER LEVEL. OR TO BE FUN AND
EIGHTY HOLD HARMLESS AND MAY
BE- SCHOOL DON'T NECESSARILY
SEE THE GROWTH THEY WOULD
OTHERWISE IT'S DEAN. BUT ALSO
THOSE WHO WERE OTHERWISE
DECLINING BUT NOT EXPERIENCE
THOSE REDUCTIONS- AND EIGHTY A
AND GIVEN THE VOLATILITY- IN IN
ATTENDANCE- AND THEN ALSO- AS
THE BE A BREAK EVEN THOUGHT.
ABOUT FOR THE TENANT THAT
COVERED NINETEEN CREATE- AND
GET AND ALSO GIVEN THE- FISCAL
SITUATION OF SCHOOL DISTRICT
VETERAN DECLINING ENROLLMENT.
WHICH TEND TO BE- YOU KNOW LESS
AND LESS HOT THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE LESS PREPARED FOR- I
RESPECT. THAN THOSE WHO ARE NOW
AND IT HAS A GROWING ENROLLMENT
SITUATION- WE CLOSE TO GO WITH
EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS.
RECOGNIZING THAT YES. YOU KNOW
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND
CHARTER SCHOOL THAT ARE
GROWING- WILL NOT BE THE
ADDITIONAL FOR. A SEAT AT THE
FACT THAT THAT. YOU KNOW REALLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS
PROTECT. AND PROVIDE. A LEVEL.
WELL DISTRICTS. AND ENSURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE PRONE TO FISCAL
TO. HAS THE GREATEST ABILITY BY.
ALL RIGHT I THINK THERE ARE
STILL SOME DISTRICTS THAT WILL
HAVE- QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT BUT
I REALIZE THAT IT WAS THE- THAT
THE SOLUTION TO HELP- THE MOST
AMOUNT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNI SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT. LAST ISSUES
RELATED TO- LAYOFFS AND WE DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT- RESOURCES THIS
BUDGET. FEDERAL FUNDING AND
POTENTIALLY DEFERRALS. MAKE
SURE. SCHOOL THANK OVER THE
LAST YEAR SO THE LAYOFFS IS
ISN'T THAT- CONCERNING BECAUSE
THERE SHOULDN'T THERE REALLY
SHOULDN'T BE- THE NEED- EXCEPT
FOR A COUPLE POTENTIAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ONE OF WHICH IS MY
HOME DISTRICT RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO WHERE THEY HAVE
OTHER FINANCIAL PROBLEMS THAT
ARE- MULTI YEARS IN THE MAKING
AND SO WHAT HAPPENS WITH THOSE
FEW SCHOOL DISTRICTS THAT HAVE
BEEN GOING THROUGH THAT FAKE AT
PROCESS AND- OF HAVE YOUR
FINANCIAL. US AND THEY WERE
POTENTIALLY GONNA BE LOOKING
AT. JUST TO DEAL WITH THEIR-
BUDGET SITUATION- NOT EVEN
CONSIDERING THAT THAT THE
CUPBOARD SITUATION- WHAT DO WE
SAY TO THOSE SCHOOL DISTRICTS.
YEAH THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION
AND- TO BE QUITE HONESTWITH
YOU- I HAD NOT THAT DOWN WITH
MY TEAM AND DISCUSS
SPECIFICALLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
AT YOU KNOW IN FACT THAT HE'S-
CASE AND SO IF IT IF IT'S ALL
RIGHT AND I CAN DO THIS IN THE
NEXT YOU KNOW. THIRTY FIVE
AVERAGE BACK WITH MY TEAM AND-
GET AN ANSWER ON THAT QUESTION
FOR YOU- AN EMAIL TO YOU AND
YOUR STAFF I'M I'M HAPPY TO DO
THAT. YEAH I DON'T THINK IT'S-
JUST THE SEX CITY THERE ARE
SEVERAL OTHERS THROUGHOUT-
CALIFORNIA. WHO HAVE THE SAME
QUESTION SO. BUT YES PLEASE GET
BACK BEFORE ONE THIRTY THANK
YOU. OKAY BUT WERE YES-
OBVIOUSLY AYE AYE YEAH I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR OF THOSE WHO
WORK SO HARD ON THIS BUDGET
BECAUSE I'M OF THE FUNDING OUR
SCHOOLS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
TO ALL OF US SO WHEN I THANK
YOU FOR THAT THERE IS SOMETHING
AS POINTED OUT BY MY COLLEAGUE
THERE'S GREAT CONCERN ABOUT
WHAT WE DOING WITH ABA AND I'VE
HAD MY OFFICE IS BEEN. WITH
CALLS AS WELL AS TO MY-
PERSONAL LINES HAVE BEEN
FLOODED WITH CALLS. BECAUSE WE
ARE TRULY IT DEVIATING FROM OUR
NORMAL PRACTICE OF FUNDING
STUDENTS AND LEADING THE MONEY
BOTTLE. THE CHILDREN WHERE
THEY'RE GOING AND SO. THERE ARE
SOME ALL SUCCESSFUL SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFUL
DOING. THE PANDEMIC WHOEVER
TRACK TO THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
AND NOW. ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE
ANY DOLLARS TO GIVEN TO THOSE
STUDENTS AND- SO WHICH MAKES IS
GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT. FOR
THEM TO CONTINUE THEIR
OPERATION- SOME IN SACRAMENTO
SOME UP AND DOWN THE STATE AND
SO. THE WORD IS THAT AND SAYS
TRULY A DEVIATION FROM IT. THE
WORD IS THAT THAT THERE'S GOING
TO BE SOME EFFORT IN OF. AUGUST
TO TRY TO. DO SOMETHING TO
CORRECT THIS PROBLEM IS THAT
IT. KATE WHEN I OF A LOT.
CHOOSE THE DOT. WHAT THEM AND
THEN WHEN I HAVE OTHER SCHOOL
THAT DON'T A KID WILL HAVE WAR
RE THEN WE WOULD THINK THEY
WOULD HAVE IN ORDER TO KEEP
THOSE SCHOOLS HOPE BUT THEY
DON'T HAVE THE CHILDREN
THEMSELVES HAVE WE YEAH WE ARE
WE PLANNING CONTINGENCY PLAN
BASED ON ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
OR SOMETHING THAT MIGHT BE
COMING THROUGH- TO HELP THOSE
SCHOOLS THAT ARE STRUGGLING AND
THAT I'VE ALREADY MADE
DECISIONS THIS ALL TIMES DUKE
SO. QUICKLY IN SOME CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE RECRUITING
STUDENTS THEY'VE ALREADY AHA
BOB MADE DECISIONS ABOUT OF
STAFFING THAT THEY NEED THE
CLASSROOM SIZES THEY MAY EVEN
ENROLL STUDENTS AND WE'RE JUST
A PROBABLY A MONTH OR SO AWAY
FROM WHEN MANY OF THEM OPEN AND
NOW THEY'RE BEING TOLD THAT
THOSE STUDENTS WILL BE FUNDED
WHAT HAVE WE ARE WE PLANNING
AND WITH MANY OTHER PLAN IN
PLACE TO BASICALLY RESPOND TO
THIS RATHER THAN THE WHOLE CAR
RULE WHICH- ARE SOUNDS GOOD ON
THE SURFACE BUT REALLY DOES
NOT- ADEQUATE. TWENTY I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THAT BUT NOT. THE
KIDS. E HAVE ANY OTHER PLAN
THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE KEEP SAYING
THAT THEY THINK THERE'S
SOMETHING ELSE. ARE WE PLANNING
ANYTHING ELSE TO DEAL WITH THIS
PROBLEM ARE WE GOING TO LET
THESE FOLKS SUFFER. FOR AN
ENTIRE YEAR WITHOUT THE
RESOURCES. I MEAN JESSICA SPEAK
TO THIS ISSUE AS WELL. I THINK
WE AFTER ON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND THANK YOU DOCTOR
WEBER AND SO CURRENTLY THE
BUDGET DOES NOT CONTEMPLATE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR THOSE
ENTITIES HOWEVER AND I DO
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE HAPPENING
CONVERSATION ABOUT THIS ISSUE-
SO I A I KNOW THAT IT IS. A
TOPIC OF DISCUSSION- I CAN'T
NECESSARILY COMMENT ON ON WHERE
IT'S HEADED AT THIS TIME- BUT I
KNOW THAT IT DID IT IS
SOMETHING THAT- HAD BEEN AND
THE IT'S BEEN ON THE GOVERNOR'S
MIND- AS WELL AS- YES WE'VE
HEARD FROM LEGISLATIVE. CAN
WELL THERE IS SOMETHING COMING
BACK BECAUSE I WOULD HATE TO
THINK OF THOSE ESPECIALLY SOME
SCHOOLS THAT HAVE HAD REAL
INCREASES IN A MOMENT OF NOT
HAVE THE RESOURCES TO
ACCOMPLISH THE GOALS THAT THEY
HAVE FOR THE COMING YEAR AND
THAT WOULD BE MOST UNFORTUNATE-
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT- LEARNING
LOSS AND I KNOW THERE WERE-
BILLION DOLLARS AND WHAT FOUR
FIVE BILLION A CAME IN FROM THE
FANS TO DEAL WITH THE ISSUE OF
LEARNING LOS. YEAH IS THAT
MONEY JUST FOLDED INTO THE ACT
ALLOCATION ARE WE REALLY
LOOKING AT. THOSE GROUPS WHERE
THERE HAS REALLY TRULY BRAND
SOME LEARNING LOSS- MY
UNDERSTANDING. OF FROM OF THE
DEPARTMENT. OF THE CD THAT.
THERE ARE POCKETS OF STUDENTS
AT LIKE TWENTY THIRTY PERCENT.
OF IN SOME SCHOOLS AND
COMMUNITIES WHERE THE KIDS HAVE
NEVER EVEN TURNED. THEIR ALL
THEIR THEIR A DISTANCE LEARNING
MATERIAL SO THAT THERE ARE.
FOLKS WHO WOULD NOT EVEN
ACCOUNT FOR THAT WE HAVE NOT
GONE TO FIND AND TO. SEE WHERE
THEY ARE AND WHY THE ART OF
ROLLED IN SOME KIND OF.
DISTANCE LEARNING ACTIVITY AND
MOSTLY THOSE KIDS ARE AT THE
BOTTOM AND SOME OF THE INNER
CITY SCHOOLS SO. IS MONEY
TARGETED TOWARD BETTER HAVE WE
JUST. INTO THE GENERAL FUND
BECAUSE WE- BELIEVE WE HAVE A
CRISISA WE HAVE A CRISIS AND
AS A RESULT. WE JUST OF GIVING
UP THE MONEY BASED ON EIGHTY
EIGHT THE- THE- I THINK ITS
FIBER. OF FIVE OR SIX BILLION I
CAME IN FOR SUPPOSEDLY LEARNING
LOSS FROM FITS. YES I'LL MAKE
TWO QUICK POINTS AND- JESSICA
COULD PROVIDE MORE DETAILS
WELL- FIRST- SO. THEY WERE VERY
SOURCES OF FEDERAL FUNDING-
THAT WERE PROVIDED FOR
EDUCATION BUT I THINK. WHAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO SPECIFIC.
EVER IS THEY PROVIDED OVERALL
NINE POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
TO THE STATE IN FLEXIBLE
FUNDING SO THAT COULD BE USED
FOR. A VARIETY OF PURPOSES
ACROSS IT. AS AS LONG AS IT'S
IN RESPONSE TO COPE IN NINETEEN
IMPACT. AND SAID GROUP. BEFORE
I TAKES FOR. FOUR BILLION OF
THAT SOME NEARLY HALF OF THE
OVERALL FLEXIBLE SUNDAY- FROM
THE CROWD OF OURS WE FIND A
DEDICATED SPECIFICALLY. TO
LEARNING LOSS MITIGATION BASED
ON THE IMPACT THAT WE'VE SEEN
AND THEN YOUR SECOND QUESTION
AIDS AROUND. OUT WHERE ARE
THESE FUNDS TARGETED AND THEY
ARE NOT SIMPLY BUT IN GENERAL.
I'LL SEE AT THAT TIME THEY ARE
SPECIFICALLY TARGETED- TO THE
STUDENTS MOST IN NEED THAT WAS
A MESS AND- THAT THEY- ARE MADE
TO IN THE MAIL. WE DO BELIEVE
THAT FINAL AGREEMENT REFLECTS
THAT BUT JUST YOU COULD TALK
SPECIFICALLY WITH REGARDTO
CONSTIPATION GRANT FUNDING. AND
OTHER FACTORS HOW THAT. WE'RE
GOING PURPOSES. CERTAINLY SO.
THE THAT NEEDS. THAT HAD AND
THAT WE- DON'T. HAVE ANY ON THE
ANY. WITHOUT THE ASSET AND
OTHER STUDENTS- WHO ARE AT
LOWER INCOME WE HAD STUDENTS-
WHO ARE. USED IN FOSTER CARE
STUDENTS THAT ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS- AND STUDENTS
BETTER ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS AND SO- OF THAT LARGE
PART OF FUNDING THAT YOU'RE
REFERRING TO ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION WILL GO OUT TO LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES BASED ON.
NUMBER OF STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES- TO APPROXIMATELY
TWO POINT NINE BILLION WILL BE
GOING OUT BASED ON SUPPLEMENTAL
IN CONCENTRATION GRANT FUNDING-
WHICH IS THE PORTION OF LPS.
BUT IT'S TARGETED TO I THANK AS
I MENTIONED BEFORE WE CALM
PEOPLE TREATED YOU THEN. AND
THEN AN ADDITIONAL PRACTICE ONE
BILLION. IS GOING TO BE GOING
OUT BASED AS TOTAL LPS
ALLOCATION SO THERE THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE FUNDS ARE BEING
TARGETED SPECIFICALLY TOWARD
STUDENTS TO EXPERIENCE IN A
PARKING LOT. AND I GUESS ALL
THIS IS ANECDOTAL SO UP SO YOU
REALLY DON'T HAVE ANY YOU'RE
NOT USING ANY DATA ABOUT WHAT
REALLY HAPPENED ON THE GROUND
AND OF THE WORD STUDENTS WHO
DID NOT GET ANY INSTRUCTION.
DURING THIS TIME FRAME ARE WE
IF BECAUSE IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT LEARNING LOS ONE OF THE
GREAT CONCERNS AT THE TIME WAS
THAT THIS WOULD HAVE ITS
GREATEST IMPACT OFTENTIMES OF
ONE. OF NOT NECESSARILY KIDS
WITH THE LOW INCOME BUT
BASICALLY SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOT
RESPONDING TO THE NEEDS OF KIDS
OR- OR SOMETHING OF THAT NATURE
AND WE HAVE THE DATA I
UNDERSTAND OF THOSE KIDS WHO
HAVE NOT. WHO JUST MISSING
BASICALLY WOULD NOT OF SIGNED
INTO ANY OF THE DISTANCE
LEARNING ACTIVITIES BUT JUST
MISSING FROM THIS FROM THE
SYSTEM AND ITS IT AND THAT'S
WHY I'M SO NOT USING ANY OF
THAT KIND OF DATA. TO MAKE THE-
USER THIS THE DAY WE HAVE. IT
WAS. AND SO FORTH AND SO ON
WITH REALLY. OF WANTING TO THIS
WHOLE OF LE LOS THE KIDS TRULY
ARE MISSING IN THE SYSTEM SO
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT IS THAT
CORRECT. IT WAS NOT MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION WAS
ABLE TO COLLECT ON CONSISTENTLY
ON A STATEWIDE BASIS THIS IS A
NATION MY UNDERSTANDING WAS
THAT. THERE WERE SOME-
INDIVIDUAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS
THAT PROVIDED SOME OF THE
INFORMATION TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION. HOWEVER TO GET TO
THE GOOD I THINK OF WHAT WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT WE HAVE
BUILT IN- SEVERAL
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURES IN TWO.
OF THE- BE BURNING- INDEPENDENT
PLAN- LEARNING COMMUTING
INTENDED PLAN THAT WILL
DISTRICTS AND CURSING COMING UP
BUT YOU KEEP WILL BE COMPLETING
IN SEPTEMBER. AND AT IN THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR- NOT HAVING
THAT EIGHTY HOLD HARMLESS THAT
WILL DISTRICTS ARE- ARE GOING
TO BE PROVIDED AND REDUCED WE
HAD REQUIREMENTS IN THERE
AROUND STUDENT ENGAGEMENT AND
WHAT CONSTITUTES. AN ATTENDANT
AND ENGAGEMENT AND REQUIREMENTS
AROUND- FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE
NOT TOO OLD SCHOOLS ARE NOT
ABLE TO CONTACT
I KNOW THAT WE BEGAN DISTANCE
LEARNING- UP AND DOWN THE STATE
WE IN I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
STATE DID WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL
DESTRUCTIVE I THINK WAS KIND OF
STATE COUNTY AND THE INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS WE RENEGOTIATED SOME
NEW CONTRACTS FOR DISTANCE
LEARNING- WITHOUT- SO THAT UP.
IT WAS BASICALLY A CONTRACT
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF THE MODEL
HOURS IT TO TEACH THAT IT
TEACHER HAD THIS BAND WITH-
WITH KIDS IN DISTANCE LEARNING
OR WITH THE CTIVITIES OF
DISTANCE LEARNING IT TALKED
ABOUT- NO ONE WOULD FAIL NO ONE
WOULD BE HELP. ACCOUNTABLE
BASICALLY OF WHAT WAS TAKING
PLACE AND SO FORTH AND SO ON DO
THOSE CONTRACTS DEAL ARE THEY
STILL BEING USED AS A BASIS
WOULD YOU KNOW YEAH THEY STILL
USE IT SCHOOLS ARE STILL
INVOLVED IN DISTANCE LEARNING.
I WOULD NOT BECAUSE THEY WERE
VERY LOOSE HAD NO
ACCOUNTABILITY AND NO ONE
SUPPOSED WAS GOING TO BE HARMED
ABOUT STEM. AND ALSO WE KNOW BE
BENEFITTED SO DO ARE THOSE
COUNTRIES STILL IN PLACE FOR
DISTANCE. LEARNING PROGRAMS
THAT WERE FUNDING. I CAN SPEAK
TO ANY KIND. THAT ARE LOCALLY
BARGAINS- WHAT I CAN SPEAK TO
OUR MOST THE REQUIREMENT THAT
FOR SOME OF THE- FLEXIBILITY
THAT WERE ALLOWED THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDERS- BY THE
GOVERNOR AND- THE THREE SB ONE
SEVENTEEN WHICH WAS ADOPTED BY
THE LEGISLATURE IN RESPONSE TO
POSTED NINETEEN- SOME OF. THE
FLEXIBILITY- THAT WERE ADOPTED
IN THOSE MEASURES ARE BEING
CONTINUED- BUT THOSE ARE REALLY
MOSTLY- AROUND THINGS LIKE THE
EIGHTY A HOLD HARMLESS- THERE
ARE A FEW FLEXIBILITY IS
AROUND- OF REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS- FOR VARIOUS
PROGRAMS AND PROVIDING AN
EXTENSION ON. THIS RECORDING
REQUIREMENT BUT LARGELY- THE-
THE- ALLOWANCES THAT THOSE
THOSE VEHICLES PROVIDED ARE
EXPIRING- AND IN TERMS OF.
SCHOOL PROGRAM. YES WE- RIGHT
IN THE TRAILER BILL THAT THERE
IS IN THAT QUALITY AND PRO WILL
BE CAN IN THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
SCHOOL YEAR- AND THAT YOU KNOW
ALL IT WITH THE WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ANYTHING CALLED
OUT NOT THE ALL OF THEIR LIVES
WILL BE CONTINUED AND WILL BE
APPLICABLE. SO YOU'RE SAYING
THAT THE CONTRACTS ARE EXPIRING
DO YOU KNOW WHEN THEY EXPIRE.
UNLIKE YOU I THINK THAT I CAN'T
SPEAK ANY LOCALLY BARGAIN
CONTRACT I CAN ONLY SPEAK TO
THE EXECUTIVE ORDERS AND SB ONE
SEVENTEEN- AND THE MAJORITY OF.
THE THIS IS THE FLEXIBILITY AND
THOSE- WILL NO LONGER B AND-
APPLICABLE IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE YEAR ALL RIGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON THIS
ISSUE. HI CARLOS MARQUEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION-
JUST HERE TO SPEAK TO THE HOLD
HARMLESS ISSUE THAT WAS
SURFACED IN COMMITTEE AND THANK
YOU DOCTOR WEBER FOR YOUR
COMMENTS AB. THE CALIFORNIA
CHARTER SCHOOLS ASSOCIATION- IS
DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
IMPACT OF. THE EIGHTY A HOLD
HARMLESS PROVISION BEING LOCKED
IN AT TWENTY NINETEEN. TWENTY
LEVELS FOR GROWING CHARTER
SCHOOLS I ALREADY MENTIONED
DISTRICTS GROWING DISTRICTS
WOULD ALSO BE IMPACTED.
CHARTERS WILL BE IMPACTED IN
TWO KEY WAYS FOR CHARTERS THAT
ARE ALREADY PLANNING FOR GREAT
EXPANSION PER THERE AT LEGALLY
BINDING CHARTER. AT THEY WILL
CERTAINLY DO HAVE THE
DISCRETION NOT TO EXPAND GREATS
BUT THEY WOULD HAVE TO- INFORM
FAMILIES WHO THEY'VE ALREADY
AND ROLLED OF THAT DECISION
THEY'VE SECURED FACILITIES
THEY'VE MADE THE HIRING
DECISIONS. THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY RESULT IN LAYOFFS
AND THE SECOND OF COURSE IS
THAT SOME CHARTERS HAVE YOU
SEEN A GROUNDSWELL OF INTEREST
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAVING BEEN
DISAPPOINTED BY. SOME OF THE
OLD DISTANCE LEARNING
EXPERIENCES THAT THEY'VE HAD IN
TRADITIONAL- PUBLIC SCHOOLS-
ALSO JUST WANTED TO- TO MENTION
AS WELL THAT- THE ASSOCIATION
FEEL STRONGLY THAT THE
UNCERTAINTY. IS PERHAPS AS ADD
AS POLICY ITSELF- JUMPED OUT TO
AN SO MANY GOALS WE CANNOT WAIT
UNTIL AUGUST. THIS BUDGET WILL
ULTIMATELY DICTATE DECISIONS
THEY'RE GOING TO BE MADE IN THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS SELL OUT SOME
CERTAINTY BY THE ADMINISTRATION
THAT THE ISSUE- WILL BE WORKED
ON IN RESULT WOULD CERTAINLY BE
WELCOME- WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
MEASURES IN SB NINETY EIGHT
NEED TO BE PASSED TODAY. WE
DON'T OPPOSE THAT- FRAMEWORK
MORE BROADLY- BUT WE CERTAINLY
HOPE THAT THERE'S A COMMITMENT
TO DO MORE- AND I ALSO WANT TO
JUST MENTION ON THE NâNG NON
CLASSROOM BASED ISSUE- JUST A
QUICK REVISION. THAT IN FACT IN
ORDER TO BE IN OUR CLASSROOM
BASED STE ALL IN CALIFORNIA AT
YOU HAVE TO PROVIDE
INSTRUCTION- MORE THAN 20% OF
INSTRUCTION. OUTSIDE OF THE
CLASSROOM NOT MORE THAN 80% SO
YOU DO HAVE NON CLASSROOM BASED
OPERATORS THAT ARE FIGHTING
NEAR 80% CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION-
AND VERY MUCH RELIANT ON- ON
RESOURCE CENTERS AND I THINK
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT'S MOST
DISQUIETING FOR- CHARTERS AND
FAMILIES IN OUR CLASSROOM
BEATLES WITH RESOURCE CENTERS
IT THAT. SPECIAL PATIENT
STUDENTS MOST. ALL OUT REPLY
AND THEY REALLY DO REQUIRE THAT
FITS ACCESS TO DATE THEY'VE
ALSO GONE WITHOUT DURING THIS
MXL. I'M TO LET SUGGEST THAT
NON CLASSROOM BASED AT SCHOOLS
WRIT LARGE- ARE DESERVING OF
THAT CARES ACT LEARNING LOSS
MITIGATION- IS SIMPLY. NOT WHAT
WE ARE HEARING FROM OUR
FAMILIES. AND VERTEL'S WAS WE
ARE STATE AND IS HAPPY
EXPERIENCE THE SAME LEARNING
LOSS BY. NOT CLASSROOM BASEMENT
WINDED LEARNING TAP OUT AND
WE'RE THAT. WE. WANT TO AGAIN
THANK YOU FOR. ENCOUNTERING A-
GOOD MORNING BY IS PAUL- I AM
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF PACIFIC
CHARTER INSTITUTE I'M ALSO
SITTING BOARD MEMBERS ARE FAR
SECOND A COUNTY BOARD OF-
EDUCATION- I'M SPEAKING
SPECIFICALLY TO SB NINETY EIGHT
NUMBER THIRTY SIX AND
SPECIFICALLY THAT CAP FUNDING-
THIS BLUNT INSTRUMENT FAILED TO
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND PENALIZES GREAT
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BY NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO ENROLL BECAUSE OF THE
CAP AND FUNDING. THIS ALSO THE
A HOLD HARMLESS- OFFERS NO
INCENTIVE TO FIND THE STUDENTS
WHO AREN'T APPEARING IN THE
SCHOOLS AND CERTAINLY THAT WAS
THE INFORMATION BEING PROVIDED
TO US THOSE DISTRICTS IT DID
PROVIDE THE INFORMATION THAT
THAT STUDENTS WERE BEING FOUND
AND SO WHAT INCENTIVE IS THERE
TO FIND THE STUDENTS. HOW CAN
WE ACCOMMODATE AT RISK STUDENTS
SEEKING BETTER PROGRAMS. IF THE
BETTER PROGRAMS CAN'T HAVE
ADDITIONAL STUDENTS. HOW MANY
AT RISK STUDENTS WERE NEVER
CONTACTED IN THE SPRING. HOW
MANY MORE AT RISK STUDENTS WILL
NOT BE CONTACTED IN THE FALL
HOW WE HOLD THIS ACCOUNTABLE.
PLEASE TAKE THE CAP OFF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS ESPECIALLY ARE. PRICE
AND BEST TEACHERS AND SCHOOL
THERE TOO LOOKING FOR THE
pSCHOOL DISTRICT BUT
DRAMATICALLY HARMING STUDENTS.
WE'LL BE PUTTING THE BEST THE
BEST TEAM ON THE SIDELINES. AND
FORCING A FORCING WHAT'S LEFT
TO EDUCATE OUR KIDS WE'RE IN A
CRISIS AS A ONE OF OUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS MENTIONED THE CRISIS IS
NOT ONE TO TAKE. TAKE A LARGE
PART OF A PART OF OUR
ORGANIZATION OFF OF THE TABLE
THOSE DISTRICTS ARE GROWING
SHOULD HAVE THE ABILITY TO
COMMENT THE STUDENTS THOSE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE
GROWING SHOULD BILL COME TO
STUDENTS AND THOSE DISTRICTS.
THAT ARE GROWING SHOULD BECOME
JUST A HAVE AND FOR THOSE TWO
ARE OKAY THIS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC COMMENT. OKAY SEEING
NONE LET'S GO TO SB ONE ONE SIX.
SB ONE ONE SIX IS THE HIGHER
EDUCATION TRAILER BILL ALSO
WOULD MENTION THREE PROVISIONS
UP THIS BILL I KNOW WE'VE
ALREADY DISCUSSED- THE TRIGGER
MECHANISM IN HIGHER EDUCATION
FISHING MORE BROADLY IN ITS
PLACE IN THE BUDGET- BUT FIRST-
THIS CLARIFIES- STUDENT
CENTERED FUNDING FORMULA AND
FOR CAN CALIFORNI COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AT SOME OF THE
SPENDING A DEFERRAL ITEMS THAT
WE HAVE DISCUSSED A SECOND-
THIS BILL INCLUDES PROVISIONS
RELATED TO CAL GRANTS AND
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP BOTH
OF WHICH WEREGENERALLY
MAINTAINED- IN THIS BUDGET
RELATIVE TO THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT AND THEN THE THIRD
IS SOME PROVISIONS RELATED TO
THE GOLDEN STATE TEACHER GRANT
PROGRAM. THIS IS A TEACHER
TRAINING PROGRAM- UP WHICH-
FUNDING THAT WAS APPROPRIATED
LAST YEAR WOULD BE AT REDUCED
BUT WHAT THE REST. OF
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FUNDS ABOUT
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS ON
THIS BILL. REQUEST. SINGLE
QUESTIONS ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
PUBLIC. ANY PUBLIC COMMENT ON.
THIS BILL. FIFTY ONE ONE SIX.
OKAY SINGLE PUBLIC COMMENT
THAT'S IT SO WE APPRECIATE WE
KNOW THE COUPLE ASK ANY
QUESTIONS FOR QUESTIONS THAT WE
HOPE TO SEE YOU DON'T GET
ADDRESSED IN THE NEXT HOUR WE
PUSH SESSION BACK TO ONE THIRTY
SO- FREE SHEET- FINANCE AN
ALLEY FOR JOINING US TODAY AND
WE WILL BE. THANK YOU. FOR.